COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
MERGING SEA AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATOR THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST IMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING A FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
NONE OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY SO WE
WILL HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE
WONDERFUL. IN CAPITAL IN THE
CAPITAL ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
WITH ME OUR SENATORS CORTESE
DOLLY GLAZER MCGUIRE ACCIONES
VOTE AND PAM. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SEE TO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PROTEST BEEN
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE
FOUR. TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. FOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND PLEASE WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE AND YOU DID AND YOU ARE THEN
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN THE
IN THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO THE
NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. AND SO ALL
INTERESTED. PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVEN
BILL ONTO IS. ITEM SIX SB
SEVENTY AUTHORED BY SENATOR
RUBIO HAS BEEN PULLED AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR WE HAVE
FOUR BILLS ON CONSENT. THOSE
BILLS ARE ITEM SEVEN SB NINETY
SEVEN. ITEM EIGHT SB TWO NINETY
ONE. I AM TWELVE SB FOUR THIRTY
SIX AND ITEM FOURTEEN SB TWO
TWO EIGHT BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON BILLS WHAT'S
ESTABLISH A CALL ON QUORUM.
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. LEYVA HERE THEY WERE
HERE PHOTO ABOVE. THE TROUBLE
HERE CORTESE YOUR ATTENTION
HERE DALLI TALLY HERE GLAZER
HERE GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE. PAM
PAM HERE. THANK YOU MADAM
CONSULTING FIRM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THIS MORNING WILL
FIRST BE ADOPTING OUR COMMITTEE
RULES AND CURRICULUM POLICY ALL
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE RULES
AND POLICY MEMBERS DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS- THE SEEING AND
HEARING THEM A MOTION HAS BEEN
MADE BY SENATOR GLAZER. THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS AND
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE RULES
AND POLICIES ARE ADOPTED LEYVA.
HI HI PATROL BOAT. CHILUBA HIGH
CORTES OF THE ARTIST I TELL.
TALLY UGLY HI GLAZER HI MCGUIRE.
M. ALL RIGHT PAN HI. THANK YOU
MA'AM WE WILL PUT THAT ON CALL
SO THAT ARE MISSING SENATOR CAN
VOTE ARE NOW WE WILL HEAR BILLS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I WANT
TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT WE HAVE
A HARD STOP AT NOON TODAY SO
JUST KEEP THAT IN MIND AS WE
ARE ASKING QUESTIONS WE WILL
MAKE SURE ALL AUTHORS GET HEARD
TODAY. WELCOME CENTER PERCENT
PORTANTINO THANK YOU FOR BEING
ON TIME AND READY TO GO YOU'RE
GOING TO START WITH THE FIRST
BILL WHICH IS SB FOURTEEN
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING AT YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH MY STAFF AND
THE SPONSORS ON THIS BILL AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REFERENCED IN
COMMENT NUMBER SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU FOR THAT A
LOT OF GOOD COOPERATION WANTED
TO HELPING THIS BILL GET TO
WHERE IT IS TODAY. SENATOR SHAH
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA IS IN
THE MIDST OF A YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS EXACERBATED BY
COVERT NINETEEN- WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING OUR YOUTH ARE
INCREASINGLY ISOLATED AND
DISENGAGED WITH COMPRESSION
SYSTEM SAID IN A SEVEN SYMPTOMS
AT AN ALL TIME HIGH FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. ACCORDING TO
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NEARLY ONE IN
THREE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS SURVEYED REPORTED
FEELING SAD OR HOPELESS ALMOST
EVERY DAY FOR TWO OR MORE WEEKS
IN A ROW. NEARLY ONE IN FIVE
REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED ATTEMPTING
SUICIDE TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THESE CRISES AS SUCH SHOULD BE
TRAINED TO IDENTIFY AND HELP
STUDENTS WHO ARE SUFFERING. I
SCHOOL BEGINS TO TRANSITION TO
IN PERSON LEARNING TEACHERS ARE
BOUND TO BE FACED WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES
RESULTING FROM THE EMOTIONAL
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC ON THEIR
STUDENTS SB FOURTEEN ENSURES
THAT STUDENTS ABSENCES FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONCERNS ARE
DEALT WITH ON PAR WITHTHE WAY
SCHOOLS EXCUSE ABSENCES FOR
PHYSICAL HEALTH. APPOINTMENTS
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRED THE CAL
DEPARTMENT A- TO IDENTIFY AND
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED EVIDENCE
BASED TRAINING PROGRAM ON YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO TRAIN
CLASSIFIED AND CERTIFIED STAFF.
CD WOULD BE REQUIRED TO DECIDE
DISSEMINATE THE SELECTED
TRAINING PROGRAM. TO ELEAZAR AT
NO COST BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AND THE L. E. H. WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CERTIFY THAT CD.
THAT AT LEAST 50% OF ITS
CLASSIFIED AND CERTIFIED STAFF
HAVE OBTAINED THE TRAINING.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL WOULD
ALSO ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO OFFER
TRAINING TO TENTH TO TWELFTH
GRADE STUDENTS. SO THAT THEY
TOO CAN BE PREPARED TO
RECOGNIZE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND ASSIST THEIR PEERS
AND GETTING THE HELP THEYNEED
FROM THE APPROPRIATE SCHOOL
PERSONNEL. YOUR HEALTH AGENCIES
THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL
DOCTORS ASSOCIATION LADY GAGA'S
BORN THIS WAY FOUNDATION
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
NEXT YEAR IN CALIFORNIA AND
IMPORTANTLY THE VOICES OF
STUDENTS INCLUDING JENNA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNCILS IN CALIFORNIA
STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS
ASSOCIATION. SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ON THE PHONE TODAY I HAVE
DOCTOR LEANDER CLARK HARVEY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES AND HARRY BRUHL WHO IS
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF PATH
POINT. AND A PARENT WHO
TRAGICALLY LOST THEIR CHILD TO
SUICIDE NOW IS THE TIME TO ACT
SO WE'RE BEST PREPARED AS WE
TRANSITION FROM THE PANDEMIC.
OBVIOUSLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE WOULD LOVE YOU TO
HEAR FROM MY CONSTITUENTS.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO WE
WILL GO TO YOUR LEAD SUPPORT-
DOCTOR LEE HUNDRED CLARK HARVEY
AND HARVEY BRUNELI WILL LET
YOU TO CHOOSE WHO GOES FIRST.
PLEASE AFTERNOON MEMBERS- ARE
ALREADY. CALIFORNIA. A
COMMUNITY WHO GAVE OF THE THEIR-
WE THE CHAIR AND. WHAT THE
COALITION. I'M FEEDBACK FOR YOU
HEARING. WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
PERFECT ECONOMIST CHECK. THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH THAT AND
WE ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE-
INCLUDING THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR BEING. THAT. THE TERM
YOU ARE CUTTING OUT A LITTLE
BIT. BURNER DEVICE OF. PARDON
ME BRING AND LADY GAGA FOR NEXT
WEEK. INCITED THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH ARE YOU
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR THIRD
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG.
TEN TO FOURTEEN YEARS OLD AND
DURING THIS THANK BUT I AND
ADDS ON YOU KNOW THANK IN THE
OF THE- COPING. INCLUDING
EATING DISORDERS AND HARM
BEHAVIOR. AT BEGIN REOPENING
AND ALLOW OF WEEKS. ARCOLA
STRONGLY BUT THAT WE NEED TO
BETTER EQUIPPED TEACHERS AND
ALL STAFF ON THE FRONTLINE OF
THIS CAR. AND INCREASE ASK TO
BE HEALTH TRAINING. COLLEGE
INTERACT WITH YOU. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT SCHOOLS ARE CALM TO
GET INTO ABSENT. OR MENTAL
HEALTH. HERE TO DISCUSS THE OF
TRAINING TO RECORD THE WAR
SIGNS THAT A CRISIS GIRL AS
MEMBER AND OF WE THANK YOUNG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THAT TESTIFIED SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN HI MY NAME IS TERRY
PAROLE I'M SURE YOU KNOW PATH
MORNING MANY HOW. ACTUALLY
BASED IN EUROPE AGENTS AND
OTHER CAL I'M ALSO THE OF A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER WHO
DIED OF SUICIDE SENATOR
PORTANTINO'S BILL IN THE
LIFESAVING OF LEGISLATION I'M
HOLDING IN MY HAND THE JOURNAL
THAT MY DAUGHTER HAD TO
COMPLETE AS PART OF OUR HIGH
SCHOOL FIND IT IN A CLASS ON
CONCEPT OF IDENTITY IN
BERKSHIRE. I FOUND THIS JOURNAL
I WAS GOING. TO AFTER SHE-
RESPONSE TO PROBLEMS MERCHANTS
AGER PICTURE HER BODY RICH
COVERED SCAR AND INCLUDE UP
CATCH OF A RAY BLADE DRIPPING
IN BLOOD. SUGAR AND WROTE IN
THE JOURNAL ABOUT HEARING BOTH.
IT IS HE TO READ THE BUT NEVER
US CAL OR SCHOOL WITH. SHOULD
NEVER LEARN US PARENTS ABOUT
WHAT SHE'S. RATHER SHE JUST
WROTE IN THE PLOS VERY THOROUGH
JOURNAL I LOOK READING THAT.
EIGHT PLUS WHAT. THREE MONTHS
LATER MY DAUGHTER OF SUICIDE. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT IS IN
YOUR HEAD. OR DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
OUR STUDENTS SHE TRAINED FOR
MANY YEARS TO BE A TEACHER AND
GENERALLY WANTED HER STUDENTS
TO SIXTEEN SHE'D JUST HAD NO
IDEA WHAT TO DO AND SHE READ
THOSE STARK WARNING SIGNS MY
DAUGHTER'S JOURNAL. SHOULD LOCK
THE TRAINING AND TEACHING%
METHODS NINE IN THE DATA
FEINSTEIN. THE MENTAL ILLNESS.
AIMS TO REDRESS BY INTO. A
EVIDENCE BASED CURRICULUM AND
USING IT TO TRY BOTH. AND
STUDENTS TO ONE BREAD. THE FINE
OF CENTER OF YOUR CABLE HELP
YOU. AND TO LEARN MORE TO DO
THEY SEE THOSE SIGNED INTO. I
KNOW KNOW WHO WOULD HAVE BEEN A
TO SAVE HIS WIFE COOPER. HAD
ACT UPON INTERNET SHE'S ON THAT
JOURNAL. I SURE WE HAD HAD THE-
TO. MY DAUGHTER KIDS. AND THE
MEMORY OF SOME MANY OF YOUNG.
WHO LAW. OR STRAY. MARKERS USE.
SB FOUR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER PER NOW WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU SHARING A VERY
PERSONAL STORY WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GO TO SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. SEEING NO ONE
WILL GO TO SUPPORT AND TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NO ONE WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP FOLKS IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN MODERATE YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE DO HAVE- PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
TO SPEAK TO. THIS BILL. JUST A
MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR. WE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE EIGHTY FIVE
POINT EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS ADRIAN
SHELTON WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OUR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NOW GO TO LINE ONE OH
THREE. I WON A THREE YEAR ONE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING- THIS
WHITE THE AMOUNT BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT WE
ARE ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN. AND WE
THINK IT- A CRITICAL BILL AND
IT'S TIMELY TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS- BOARDING ARE GOING
ROUND TABLE AND- JALEN. THANK
YOU TWO WITNESSES CA INTO STATE
YOUR AND THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL PLEASE. BY. SEVENTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING RIGHT BACKING
IMBALANCE OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LEVINE. SEVENTY
FIVE. WHEN YOU START AFRESH AND
I SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
NORMA PAINTED WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
WEARING STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CELL. THANK YOU. LINE. SEVENTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING HEARING
MEMBERS CHRISTOLOGY TALKED ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIND. TWENTY FIVE.
FIND TWENTY FIVE THROUGH ONE'S
OPEN. HELLO YES MY TWENTY FIVE
YEAR ONE IS OPEN SORRY DIDN'T
TELL ME MY NUMBER MY NAME IS
CHRISTY DENNIS I AM A PARENT-
WHEN YOU'RE OLD AND A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD AND I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
WHY. NINETY SIX. GOOD MORNING
THIS ASSEMBLY GARAGE ON THE IN
HIGH SCHOOL DO AND INCOME THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH
FOUR. A GOOD MORNING DANGEROUS
BEHALF OF THE CAN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH RECURSOS CREATION OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND WE'RE IN TROMS BORDER
SB FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY. HI DOUG
ALTHOUGH I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT AT A PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL
IN THE BAY I'M PART OF CHEN UP
AND WE ARGUE CLAD ORGANIZATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I'M A CO
SPONSOR. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
EIGHT. YOU'RE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING NINE HUNDRED AND WITH
WEDDING GROUP ON BEHALF OF NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA PRACTICAL
SPONSORED JUMPED APART. THANK
YOU. LINE. EIGHTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
NICK WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW
TWO MORE WITNESSES JUST FOR
TIME CONSTRAINTS BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A ELEVEN ADDITIONAL BILLS
TO HEAR SO IF YOU CAN DO TWO
MORE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
WILL DO THE SAME GOING FORWARD
FOR ALL BILLS. YEAH YES MADAM
CHAIR AT YOUR DIRECTION WILL
NOW GO TO LINE. SIXTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BURKE WITH THE
TWENTY ONE REPRESENTING HALF
WHAT THE KAMARCK BASED IN L. A.
COUNTY NOTABLY THE TWENTY FIFTH
SENATE DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BY SEVENTY
BILL. I'M GOOD MORNING SENATORS
MINING THAT KIND OF THING AND
I'M A SENIOR WATCHING HIGH
SCHOOL PRESENTED BY TRANSCANADA
TWENTIETH I'M AGAINST I'M
WRITING TO YOU FIFTY DOLLARS IN
SUPPORT OF THE. AS YOU
FOURTEEN- AT WHILE YOU'RE IN
THE PUBLIC SYSTEM LOOK FOR.
INCOMES ARE ON MY YOURS TO TALK
ABOUT. ALL THE AMERICANS
ARTICLE GOT ONE OTHER OF SCHOOL.
THANK YOU GOING TO A DISTRICT
WITH A CULTURE IS BECOMING.
THANK YOU JUST IT. THANK YOU.
OKAY MA'AM WE HAD FIFTY CALLED
IN SUPPORT THAT WILL BE ARE NOT
GOING. ON A DAY BILL. TO THOSE
WHO DO NOT TO SEE THAT THEY
WERE IN SOME PLEASE SEND US
LETTER WE'RE NOT GOING TO THE
SAME PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION. DO
WE HAVE ANY ON THE LINE FOR
LEASE OPPOSITE I DON'T THINK SO.
I'M SORRY. OKAY HEARING NONE DO
WE HAVE ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
MYSTERON A WRITER DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE- WE
WOULD CAUTION THAT IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN SUPPORT WE ARE ONLY
TAKING BOWS THAT ARE CALLING IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY HAVE
SPOKEN TO AN OPERATOR ALREADY
AND WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE NEED TO DISCUSS
ONE ZERO AGAIN AT THIS TIME.
WELL NOW HERE FROM LINE TWENTY
ONE. MADAM CHAIR TONY TO GUERO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERSASSOCIATION I WANTED
TO JUST BE ON RECORD WE HAVE A
MEETING WITH THE BILL'S
SPONSORS AND STAFF TOMORROW AND
SO WE WERE UNPREPARED TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE ISSUES AROUND
TRAINING SO WE ARE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. MA'AM. MADAM
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WHO
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR. WE WILL GO BACK
TO THE AUTHOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I WOULD- OBVIOUSLY YOU
HEARD A VERY POIGNANT STORY
FROM A FATHER I HOPE MEMBERS
WHO WANT TO. SORRY WE NEED TO
GO BACK YOU COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SORRY ABOUT THAT I'M%
JUST TRYING TO TIME THIS FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH
ALL THESE BILLS IN THE NEXT TWO
AND A HALF HOURS SO I'M A
LITTLE BIT TO A LITTLE BIT
PREOCCUPIED WITH THAT THE
STREET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WHO HAS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR PAM I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AT FIRST I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
DIAZ WE HAD WORKED TOGETHER ON
A PREVIOUS- BILL TO ALSO DO
MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING BACK IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH WAS
UNFORTUNATELY- DETERRED BUT MY
THINGS I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT- I HEARD.
TEACHERS EXETER EXPRESS YOU
KNOW. THE SIMPSONS. IS THAT.
THE PURPOSES BILL- THIS BILL IN
OUR PRIOR BILL. AND THAT WAS TO
REALLY. DO MENTAL HEALTH FIRST
AID IT'S NOT TO SAY THAT-
TEACHERS OR SCHOOL STAFF. HAVE
TO PROVIDE FULL TREATMENT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH. AND THAT THEY
WOULD BE ON THE WOULD BE THE
ONES. THAT THOSE RESOURCES NOT
BE AVAILABLE. SO CERTAINLY I
APPRECIATE AND I'M SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BUT ALSO. SAYING
THAT. WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TO GET. MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
TO SCHOOLS. KNOWING THAT WITH
THE TEACHERS AND STAFF ON THE
FRONT LINES TRAINING THEM TO BE
ABLE TO BETTER IDENTIFY AND
GIVING THEM SOME TOOLS SO THAT
THEY CAN. PROVIDE SOME INITIAL
HELP. DOES NOT. PRECLUDE OUR-
OUR COMMITMENT TO TRY TO GET
RESOURCEFUL RESOURCES FOR
MENTAL HEALTH ACCESS IN
SCHOOLS. AND WITH THAT AND I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO THE BILL TO
PROTECT. THE DECEMBER PAN ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
BETTER VICE CHAIR. IS THE QUICK
COMMENT AS A MOTHER OF. THREE
KIDS- WHO ARE JUST WENT TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL OR TO THAT JUST
WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL. I
UNDERSTAND. THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT- ASSESSING AND REALLY TAKE
TAKING NOTE OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH.
S. CENTER PORTANTINO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE EFFORTS OF.
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
BRINGING IN SHEDDING LIGHT TO
IT AND- AND REALLY AB HELPING
OUR- OUR- EDUCATORS S. B. MORE
AWARE OR AT. JUST BE MORE AWARE
OF THE SITUATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR EFFORT. THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SAYING
NONE. MISREPORTING PLEASE CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. WE THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMENTS FROM YOUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL-
LISTENING TO MR BRUHL TALK
ABOUT HIS FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
DAUGHTERS- JOURNAL I THINK. IS
A POWERFUL STATEMENT OF WHY
THIS TRAINING IS NEEDED- WE ARE
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SCHOOL PESONNEL TO BE TRAINED
SO THEY CAN HELP. NOT BE THE
END PROVIDERS OF THE SERVICE
BUT THE DIRECTORS OF WHO MIGHT
NEED THAT SERVICE AND I THINK
THAT'S A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
POINT- AS YOU KNOW SUICIDE IS A
PERSONAL ISSUE TO ME AS WELL.
HAVING LOST A BROTHER TO
SUICIDE- THIS IS THE TIME TO DO
THIS THE NEED IS NEVER BEEN
GREATER- AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAM TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
FOURTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA. HI IF
I GO TO A BUG HI THE TRAVEL BUG
BITES COURTESY I. ATTEND THE
AYE DALY. KELLY HI GLAZER HI
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. PAM HI AN
HIGH. THANK YOU BELIEVE THE
BILL ON CALL FOR ME ON AND
REMOVE. SAID REPORT YOU HAVE S.
B. TWO TWO FOUR PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
REFERENCED IN COMMON NUMBER FOR
THE COMMITTEE OUT ANALYSIS AND
AGAIN COMPLEMENT TO. COMMITTEE
STAFF AND MY STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WELL
TOGETHER TO GET US TO THIS
POINT SB TWO TO FOUR IS.
SOMEWHAT OF A COMPANION BILL TO
SB ONE FOURTEEN- AS WE KNOW
MENTAL HEALTH IS CRITICAL TO
OVERALL WELL BEING AND THE
ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF OUR
STUDENTS. PINE RECOGNIZE AN
UNTREATED EARLY TREATED MENTAL
ILLNESS ELEVATES THE RISK OF
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS SUCH AS
SUICIDE AND SELF INJURY INJURY.
AND IT DIMINISHES THE PROSPECTS
FOR RECOVERY AND CAN CONTRIBUTE
TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND OTHER
NEGATIVE COPING BEHAVIORS
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING AT LEAST ONE IN FIVE
YOUTH LIVE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. MENTAL HEALTH
EDUCATION EDUCATION IS ONE OF
THE BEST WAYS TO INCREASE
AWARENESS AND EMPOWER STUDENTS
TO HELP- BY REDUCING THE STIGMA
ASSOCIATED WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM IS THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE SETTING
FOR PROVIDING THIS EDUCATION TO
ALL STUDENTS. GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THERE IS NO STATE MANDATED
HEALTH EDUCATION COURSE AT THE
MIDDLE OR HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL IN
CALIFORNIA. ON MENTAL HEALTH
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS DO NOT RECEIVE ANY
INSTRUCTION IN MENTAL HEALTH SB
TWO TO FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE'S BETWEEN GRADES ONE AND
TWELVE RECEIVED. AN AGE
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH
EDUCATION FROM A QUALIFIED
INSTRUCTOR AT LEAST ONCE DURING
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL ONCE DURING
MIDDLE SCHOOL. AND ONCE DURING
HIGH SCHOOL. SO I HAVE A- WE
WILL TO HELP IDENTIFY STUDENTS
AT RISK BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
HELP STUDENTS UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE FACING
WITH THIS ISSUE AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST OBSERVATIONS I'VE FOUND
AS I'VE PROPOSED THESE BILLS IS
PEOPLE COME UP TO ME AND ASK.
WHAT HAPPENS OF A STUDENT IS
FAKING. AND I ALWAYS SAY WE
DON'T ASK THAT QUESTION WHEN A
STUDENT HAS A COLD. DON'T ASK
THAT QUESTION WHEN A STUDENT.
SAYS THEY HAVE OHER PHYSICAL
ISSUES SO THAT EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS AND AN UNDERSTANDING
IS IMPORTANT EDUCATION IS WHERE
IT SHOULD HAPPEN IN SCHOOL SO
ON THE PHONE TODAY I HAVE
SOVIET TRACTORS PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWER
NETWORK. AND TERRYCAME WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
YOUR ANALYSIS IS A LONG LIST OF
AGENCIES. THAT SUPPORT THIS
BILL I ALSO WANT TO MENTION TO
PATHWAY SYCAMORES WAS LEFT OFF
THE ANALYSIS. AND I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE LISTED AS
WELL AND SO WHAT I WOULD LOVE
MY TO- SPEAKERS TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THEIR
THOUGHTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE GO TO THE
COASTLINE SO THAT OUR- LEAD
SUPPORT CONTEST FIVE. WE
SUPPORT YOU HAVE TO MINUTES
EACH. HELLO MY NAME IS LOOKING
AT TRAXLER AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK ALSO
KNOWN AS K. AND- FOR THE
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH PROGRAM
OF MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA YEAH. 101% LED BY
CONDITIONAL YOU HAVE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE TODAY. SIX AB CLOSED.
ABSOLUTE TWENTY FOUR BECAUSE OF
THE BENEFITS OF WOULD PROVIDE
TO THE- AGE YOUTH ATHLETES ONE.
HI RICHARD FIVE AND THERE ARE
COST. AMONG HEALTH. ARE
INDICATIVE OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS THAT IS NOT THE
ADEQUATELY TO. YOU CAN
SEPARATION THIS BILL. YOU CAN
NOT CONTINUE TO WOBBLE WHILE
THE- BECAUSE DOING SO ONLY
PERPETUAL THE HARD. ONCE I
ATTEMPTED AND WAS COMMITTED
SUICIDE FACILITY I WAS ONLY FOR
YEARS. FOUR YEARS LATER I LOOK
BACK WITHOUT FOR MOBILE AND ONE
GIRL AND I WISH THAT I HAD BEEN
EQUIPPED WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND
RESOURCES I SUGGEST THAT WE
NEEDED WIDELY ACCEPTED .COM. I
WAS A CHILD. EXPECTED TO LEARN
HOW TO TAKE FOR. ANY MOTIVATED
IN MY MENTAL. WITHOUT ANY HELP
OF THE- TO TEACH HOW TO DO THAT
AT THAT. THIS IS A COMMON. THE
TO THE INVOLVED ONE ONE. EIGHT
SHOULD BE DOING EVERYTHING IN
ITS POWER TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE
WHICH- IN JAPAN MULTIPLE HEALTH
CARE. WITH THE CLASS. WALDRON
ON HOW THE CONCLUSION ON THE
AVAILABLE TO SUIT. ALLOWING
THEM BACK WHILE FIND AGAINST
ALMOST ONE THOUSAND THAT HERE'S
AND GET TO CHOOSE IS WHAT
HAPPEN. AND I. HEALTH. AS YOU
WERE OFF MARKETED POWER
FOOTBALL PRACTICE. YEAR THE
CHANGE IN MY DISTRICT BODIES
ACTIVISTS ONE. WHY ADULTS LIKE
YOU DON'T LISTEN TO ADVOCATE
WHILE. I HOPE IT WILL FOR THIS
WITH US AS THE- TO FIGHT THE
ONE ON. AND HEALTH RESEARCHERS.
THIS YEAR MARKS. THE OFFICE
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THE WITNESS. TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KERRY
CAMP DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AND ADVOCACY AT
CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE WE ARE A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA LINE
TO CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
ONE OF THE BILL'S CO SPONSORS
ON BEHALF OF THE NEARLY THIRTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN FAMILIES WE
CERTAIN LOS ANGELES CHILDREN'S
INSTITUTE STRONG SUPPORT SB TWO
TWENTY FOUR TRUST SIMPLE TIME
TEEN AND ADULT TO LA A
HEALTHIER HAPPY LIFE. CENTRAL
TO OUR WORK IN THE BILL RAP
BROWN SHOT PROVIDING TRUMP
RESEARCH TO STRENGTHEN AND
PROMOTE PERSONAL AND COMMUNITY
FOR HEALING WELLNESS AND
SUCCESS WE DID THAT NETWORK OF
REALLY AND CENTERS BEHAVIOR
HELPS FAMILY STERN PRO. AS TEAM
HEALTH PROVIDER WE KNOW THAT
SOCIAL MOST TO THE IT'S CHRIS
TO LEARNING WELL BEING AND
SUCCESS IN LIFE INCREASING OUR
WORK OUR INTENTION PARTNERS
WITH CAN READ. ARE EXPOSED
VIOLENT PROGRAMS A WITH THE LAW
ANGELES CITY AND POLICE WE
EMOTIONAL THE TO CHILDREN
FAMILIES HAVE WITNESSED
COMMUNITY. THERE SCHOOL
INITIALLY WE INTO AND HELP
SUPPORT BY TRAINING TRICKS AND
QUICKLY TROUBLING FOR SCHOOLS
CHILDREN WHO DISTRICT SUFFER
FROM LOW OF EXPOSURE TO HAD HAD
THE BY NINETY AND INEQUITIES
HAVE ONLY FOR CAN YOU OF COLOR
AND HEALTH NEEDS A THING THAT
TO HAVING DURING THE TEN WITH.
I IN THE TEN TO CURRY AT
YOUNGER SO WHAT BETTER TO
DEEPEN OUR SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN
AT A SCHOOL SB CHICO FOUR CREE
A SAFE PLACE FOR ALL STATE
THREE AND ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
MOST WELL BEING SB TWO FOUR ONE
POWER YOU WITH THE. EXACTLY
JUST THE PASSAGE OF SB TWO
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER. THANK YOU WILL NOW GO
TO SUPPORT YOUR IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP ANYONE IN
SUPPORT WILL TAKE THE FIRST
FIFTEEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM LINE.
THIRTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
NORMA PEYTON I'M WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION WHERE THE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF SB TWO TO FOUR AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY SIX.
TWENTY SIX HAS NOT RESPONDED
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE
NINETEEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SPYING. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ADRIAN SOMETHING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE AT CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES EIGHT CROWD
CO SPONSOR OF SB TWO TWO FOUR
THANK YOU. ONE ONE EIGHTEEN.
PARDON ME MADAM CHAIR JUST A
MOMENT NO PROBLEM FIND WHAT.
ONE OH NINE. YOUR LINE IS UP
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN CHARGE
SEVEN R. J. NOT STUDENTS AT THE
HOTLINE DIRECT AT THE YOU DO
FOR THINKING THANK YOU. WHY ONE
THIRTY SO. GOOD MORNING MADAM
AND WILLIAM A READING BEHALF OF
THE CHARACTER SIXTY OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS I WOULD SUPPORT
ABOUT FORWARD IN THE QUALITY OF
THE WORK WITH YOUR IN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY SEVEN.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE AND I AM
A STUDENT BOARD MEMBER AND
LONGTIME UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SENATE DISTRICT
SEVEN AND THE REPRESENTATIVE
BOB JOHN UP THINKING STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE FAILED THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FIND. SEVENTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
ARE PRIVILEGE ON BEHALF OF THE-
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
CALIFORNIA CARRYING A CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. HEY I'M I'M
COMING AN ORGANIZER FOR JANICE
FREMONT CHAPTER AND GET EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT PRESS THREE TO
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY THREE. I'M SHERIN MEMBERS
DANNY OFFER WITH THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NOBBY CALIFORNIA ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BY. SEVENTY SEVEN. WILL MOVE ON
TO LINE THIRTY SIX. NINE THIRTY
SIX AWARENESS OPEN. PARDON ME
MADAM CHAIR WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
THE LINE ONE FORTY TWO. HELLO
AIRMAP THE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU. BUYING
SIXTY EIGHT. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ROB LAND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES AND
STRONG SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO
TWO FOUR. THANK YOU. FIND. ONE
OH FOUR. HI GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS NAMES CHANCERAPS
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA I'M
STATING THAT WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWO TO COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT WAS
OUR FOURTEENTH WITNESS WERE
GONNA TAKE ONE MORE. BLIND. ONE
FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING SENATORS
MY NAME IS A SHAKE ON THE
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF EDUCATION-
THE LOWLIGHTS SCHOOL SENIOR AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO TWO FOUR. THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW GO THROUGH THE SAME
PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION THERE IS
NO LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE WILL
GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE FOR
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WE WILL
GO TO TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE
THERE MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION. SB. TWO TO FOUR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO PRESS ONE AND. ZERO THE
MANAGER WITH SOME PEOPLE HAVE
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU SIR.
PARDON ME JUST
AGAIN ONE MOMENT MADAM CHAIR NO
PROBLEM.
AND I'M SURE I
APOLOGIZE WE APPEAR TO BE
EXPERIENCING ANY TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY THERE IS ONLY ONE
PERSON WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THAT A SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL YOUR
LINE IS NOT BEEN ACCESS BY AN
OPERATOR I'M GOING TO OPEN YOUR
PHONE LINE AND ALLOW YOU TO
SPEAK. JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE ONE FIFTY YEAR ONE IS OPEN
IF YOU'RE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
SPEAK NOW. THE MANAGER AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE I BELIEVE WE'LL HAVE
A RESOLUTION IN JUST A MOMENT
NO PROBLEM MODERATOR YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALL LIVING IN A NEW WORLD
SO YEAH I THINK YOU'RE DOING A
GREAT JOB THANK YOU. SHE THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON S. B. TWO TWO FOUR.
YES GENERATION HERE. BUT JUST
LEVINE ONE FIFTY. MADAM CHAIR
PARDON ME ONE ONE FIFTIES LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE PLEASE MAKE.
WHAT I GUESS I'M A DOG TODAY
THE CORRUPTION KNOWS NO LIMITS
NO ONE IS AGAINST MODERATED TO
HELP OUR CHILDREN OPEN BUT
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE. HELLO SENATOR A
PORTANTINO JUST A QUICK
QUESTION I NOTICED IN YOUR
FIRST BILL- THERE WAS A
STATEMENT ON THERE THAT- THERE
WAS LANGUAGE THAT SAID IT
SHOULD ONLY BE IMPLEMENTED TO
THE EXTENT THAT AN
APPROPRIATION IS MADE IN THE
BUDGET ACT. IS THAT INCLUDEDI
DID NOT READ THAT HERE IS NOT
INCLUDED AS WELL AND THIS. ON
THIS BILL I DO NOT BELIEVE IT
IS INCLUDED IN THIS BILL AT
THIS POINT BUT OBVIOUSLY THE
BILLS GO TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE NEXT. OKAY I'M JUST A
CHAIR I'M SORRY I KNOW THE
CHAIR. OKAY I JUST WANT IT AS A
AS A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
AND- I JUST I'M ALWAYS AFRAID
OF MANDATES THAT DON'T COME
WITH FUNDING SO I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF WE'RE
GOING TO IMPLEMENT WHICH I
THINK IS A GREAT IDEA. JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO HAVE THE FUNDING
TO BE ABLE TO MEET. THIS
MANDATE. THAT I HAVE. I HAVE
EVERY HOPE TO. HAVE INCREASE
FUNDING FOR BOTH BILLS
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS MONEY FOR SB
FOURTEEN IN THE BUDGET. THE
RELATIVE TO- MENTAL HEALTH SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT. WE CAN MAKE
SURE OF ALL THAT ARE PROPERLY
FUNDED BUT- I ALSO SAY. WE'RE
PUTTING A LOT OF LOCAL CONTROL
INTO S. B. TWO TWO FOUR. TO
ALLOW DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT
THIS- SORT OF WITHIN THEIR OWN
SYSTEM. AND SO I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THEY COULD
ACCOMMODATE IF WE DON'T END UP
HAVING A DIRECT FUNDING SOURCE.
BUT IT'S JUST TOO IMPORTANT NOT
TO CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION
SO THANK YOU. OKAY I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR. SENATOR GLAZERS. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. CENTER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
FORWARD I'M PLEASED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF IT AND I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON. THE WHOLE
PACKAGE OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT YOU ARE ADVANCING THIS
YEAR IT. MATCHES UP WELL WITH
THE THREE BILLS I HAPPEN THAT
SAME SUBJECT AREA WHICH- WE
BOTH KNOW IS- IT'S BEEN IGNORED
AND APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND HAPPY WITH THE BILL THE
PURPOSE. OF CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS OF THE
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING HER ONE LAST COMMENT
SORRY CENTER BROKE. PERSONALLY
CORRECT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZERS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
PORTANTINO- AGAIN HAS BEEN SAID
TO- THE TIME IS NOW TO PUT IN
PLACE EVERYTHING WE NEED TO
HELP OUR KIDS SUCCEED GOING
FORWARD AND A HEALTHY HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS. OFTENTIMES WE AS
PARENTS- WE DON'T. WE DON'T
EMBRACE THE INTELLIGENCE AND
THE MATURITY OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN THEM
GROW UP AS AS LITTLE KIDS INTO
TEENAGERS AND THIS BILL RENEWS
THE FAITH IN OUR USE THAT IF
THEY'RE EMPOWERED THEY'LL HELP
EACH OTHER HAVE A SAFER
HEALTHIER HIGH SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO THE BILLS
THE MOVE A CENTER GLAZER MENEM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. TWO TWO
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA BYE BYE
BYE CHAU ABODE I TROUBLED BY
COURTESY I ATTEND THE HI DELHI.
DELHI HI GLAZER AYE LASER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN ALL RIGHT AND I
REMEMBER CONSULTANT WILL LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL FOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE MEMBERS I JUST WANNA
LET YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO EXTEND OUR TIME IN THE ROOM
TO ONE O'CLOCK. I AM VERY
HOPEFUL WE CAN GET THROUGH ALL
THE BILLS BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
ANY MEMBERS TO LOSE THEIR BILLS
TODAY AND GET POSTPONED TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE BUT WE ALL KNOW
HOW THAT WORKS WE KEEP
POSTPONING TOWARDS THE END OF
SESSION FOLKS WILL NOT GET TO
HAVE THEIR BILLS HEARD SO THAT
CENTER PORTANTINO IF YOU COULD
PLEASE. PRESENT ON SB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND COMMITTING- YES
TOOTH SEVEN REQUIRE ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE SCREENED. FOR
THE RISK OF DYSLEXIA AND THEIR
EARLY AND A MENTOR YEARS.
DYSLEXIA IS THE MOST COMMON
DISABILITY. YOURS TRULY HAS A
FORM OF ID AS WELL AFFECTING UP
250% OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY STUDENTS
AT. AT PROMISE FOR SUCCESS
STRUGGLE TO READ AT GRADE LEVEL
AND NEVER MASTER CORE ACADEMIC
CONTENT. OFTEN THE STUDENTS ARE
NEVER IDENTIFIED WILL RECEIVE
THE EARLY INTERVENTION THEY
NEED TO AVOID GOING THROUGH
THEIR SCHOOL CAREER STRUGGLING
TO READ. AND KEEP UP WITH THEIR
PEERS IN SCHOOLS LATER IN LIFE.
BUT THAT IDENTIFICATION AND
SUPPORT STUDENTS AT RISK FOR
DYSLEXIA ARE LESS LIKELY TO
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND ATTEND
COLLEGE LAND JOBS. WHEN THEY
WANTED FACE GREATER RISKS OF
INCARCERATION. IN SOME PRISONS
TODAY. NEARLY. 80% OF THE
INMATES. HAVE LEARNING
DISABILITIES THAT ARE ON THE
DYSLEXIA SPECTRUM. SB TWO THREE
SEVEN WILL HELP ELIMINATE
INEQUALITIES OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS. BY
REQUIRING LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY SERVING STUDENTS IN
GRADES KINDERGARTEN TO ANNUALLY
SCREEN EVERY STUDENT FOR THE
RISK OF DYSLEXIA. THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION MOST
APPLICATION APPROVED LIST OF
CULTURALLY LINGUISTICALLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SCREENING TOOLS. AND SCREENING
RESULTS WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE
TO TEACHERS AND PARENTS THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ENGLISH LEARNING
STUDENTS. THAT WILL HAVE A BIG
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
SENSITIVE SO WE DON'T OVER
IDENTIFY UNNECESSARILY. WITHOUT
UNIVERSAL SCREENING MANY
STUDENTS WITHOUT SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES AND ADVOCACY ON THEIR
BEHALF WILL NOT BE IDENTIFIED
AT RISK. FOR BEING DYSLEXIA
DYSLEXIC AND RECEIVE THE
APPROPRIATE INSTRUCTION AND
SUPPORT THEY NEED THEY NEED. TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT EARLY
IDENTIFICATION AND- FOR
INTERVENTION WHICH
SCIENTIFICALLY BASED READING
INSTRUCTION STRATEGIES ARE
MATERIALS IMPROVE LITERACY
OUTCOMES. FOR STUDENTS THAT ARE
RISK FOR DYSLEXIA AND DELAYED
IDENTIFICATION SUPPORTS.
CLOSING THE- ACADEMIC GAPS AND
LEARNING LOSS IN CORE CONTENT
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO
OVERCOME. EVEN AFTER
SIGNIFICANT COST INTERVENTIONS
UNIVERSAL EARLY SCREENING FOR
STUDENTS AT RISK CAN HELP
FAMILIES AND TEACHERS SUPPORT
THE BEST LEARNING OUTCOMES. FOR
ALL THE STUDENTS CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND HELP SCHOOL
AND HELP END THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELIE. I'M ACTIVELY
DISCUSSING THIS BILL WITH THE
PTA AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO
ENSURE. THAT WE HAVE THE
STRONGEST BILL POSSIBLE. WE
KNOW THAT MANY OF US CAN GO TO
THE FINEST PEDIATRICIANS WHEN
WE RECOGNIZE THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH OUR CHILDREN. BUT THERE IS
A SOCIAL INEQUITY AND AS SOCIAL
JUSTICE COMPONENT OF THIS NOT
EVERY FAMILY HAS THAT CAPACITY.
AND HAVING THE SCHOOLS
IDENTIFY. THE RISK FOR DYSLEXIA
WILL CERTAINLY HELP LEVEL THAT
PLAYING FIELD. ON THE PHONE
TODAY WE HAVE CORINNE WEAVER ON
BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND UP END UP-
ACP. WE ALSO HAVE NAY PUT TECHS
FROM COATING DECIDE CALIFORNIA
WHO IS ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL ALONG WITH THAT VOICE
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO LET'S GO TO THE LEAD
SUPPORT MISTER MODERATOR. HI MY
NAME IS CORY WEAVER CO FOUNDER
FULCRUM NUMBER OF LOCAL
UNIVERSITIES EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. FORMER EDL LEADERS
AND SCHOOL BASED EDUCATOR FOR
TWENTY YEARS HELLO I'M
CONNECTED TO ORGANIZATIONS
ADVOCATING THE QUALITY
PUBLICATION. EDUCATION FOR
EVERY CHILD IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
I HAVE A PERSONAL STORY ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF SB TWO THIRTY
SEVEN. MY NEPHEW ELIJAH
STRUGGLING SCHOOLS CHALLENGES
WERE TRIBUTE TO LACK OF
MOTIVATION AND EFFORT. IT
WASN'T UNTIL HE WENT TO JAIL
BUT HE WAS GOING TO THE
COLLECTION. LATER IN MY ROLE AS
UNION LEADERS I TRAIN YOU
LICENSE FORMER FIRST GRADE
TEACHER. RECENTLY DISCUSSED HOW
SEVENTEEN YEARS EARLIER OF THE
CHILD IN HER CLASS WAS
DYSLEXIC. BEHIND TEARS A
TEACHER STATED. I HAD NO IDEA.
AND THAT'S THE POINT. SCHOOLS
ARE BEING ASKED TO PROVIDE A
FREE APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
EDUCATION BUT DON'T HAVE THE G.
INFORMATION TO KNOW. WHAT MIGHT
BE APPROPRIATE. UNIFORM SCHOOL
EXPERIENCES OFTEN WITHERING
CHRISTIANS THE UCSF DYSLEXIA
CENTER CIRCUIT BY THIRD GRADE.
THE SELECTED STUDENTS OFTEN
SUFFER FROM PTSD. MY NEPHEWS
MESSAGE TO LAWMAKERS HIS. UNCLE
TELL THEM IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
SCREENING WOULD HELP THE SCHOOL
AND MY DAD FIGURE OUT WHAT TO
DO. THE WOULD REALLY HELP ME
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON SO I WENT TO JAIL. IT
WAS A HUGE WEIGHT OFF MY
SHOULDERS I THOUGHT I WAS JUST
SLOW. LAWMAKERS MY NUMBER. ON
THE CALL ME IF THEY WANT TO
TALK. HIS NUMBER IS FIVE ONE OH
EIGHT TWO NINE THREE SIX NINE
THREE. DESPITE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT IS DYSLEXIA
GUIDELINES FOR RESOLUTIONS FROM
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
CALLING FOR SCREENING. MOST
STUDENTS REMAIN ON THEIR OWN.
FAMILIES WITH RESOURCES MARKET
PRIVATE SCREEN BUT MOST
STUDENTS ARE SHUT OUT THE
BONOBOS THE SOFT BIGOTRY OF LOW
EXPECTATIONS WERE CHALLENGES
ARE SEEN. AS MORE BASIL ISSUES
OR COMMENSURATE WITH THEIR
INTELLIGENCE. I HAD NO IDEA
COULD NOT BE THE STATE'S OUR
SCHOOLS WHILE DEFERRING TO THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF PRISONS. FOR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
CORRECTION TO PROVIDE SCREENING
THE PICK UP THE PIECES OF
SHATTERED LIVES MY SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. THE SOMBER BUT WHEN
YOU KNOW BETTER YOU DO BETTER.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON. TWO THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MEGAN CO STATE DIRECTOR CUT
DISLIKED CAL TWENTY YEAR
EDUCATOR AND PARENTS OF A WITH.
DYSLEXIA IS THE SAME LARGEST
LEARNING TO AND IT ONE OF THE
GREAT COUNTRY FACT TO LOVE
READING IT. SB TWO THIRTY SEVEN
WILL SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND
EFFECTIVELY IDENTIFYING
STUDENTS AT RISK FOR DYSLEXIA
EARLY BEFORE THEY STRUGGLE I
HAVE A TWELVE YEAR OLD SIGN AS
WELL AS THE BROTHER WITH
DYSLEXIA YOUR AGES STAND THIRTY
FIVE YEARS GET THEIR
EXPERIENCES IN SCHOOL ARE NEAR
IDENTICAL THEY BOTH WERE NOT
IDENTIFIED EARLY AND THEY BOTH
WERE DENIED ACCESS TO THE
EVIDENCE BASED INSTRUCTION THEY
NEEDED TO LEARN TO READ. THEY
BOTH COULD HAVE RECEIVED EARLY
SUPPORT IN THEIR GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSROOMS THAT WOULD
HAVE ADDRESSED THEIR
DIFFICULTIES AND THEN YEARS OF
STRUGGLE THAT RESULTED IN
FRUSTRATION AND SHAME MY
BROTHER'S EXPERIENCE IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES MAY HAVE
BEEN UNDERSTANDABLE THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE IS NOT
CLEAR THEN BUT THE SCIENCE IS
CLEAR NOW AND THE FACT THAT MY
TWELVE YEAR OLD BAND EXPERIENCE
WITH A REPEAT OF ITS FORTY
SEVEN YEAR. OLD UNCLE IS
UNACCEPTABLE. WE NOW KNOW THE
READ INDICATOR OF THE- THAT ARE
HIGHLY PREDICTIVE- CAN BE
EASILY MEASURED USING GREEN
COST EFFECTIVE SCREENING
INSTRUMENT. AT THE FIRST GRADE
TEACHER I WOULD WELCOME THESE
TOOLS THEY WOULD HAVE MADE MY
JOB EASIER. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE MOST IMPACTFUL WINDOW OF
TIME FOR PROVIDING INTERVENTION
IS BEFORE AGE NINE. WITH
INTERVENTION CHILDREN WITH
DYSLEXIA CAN BECOME STRONG
READERS AND REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL. BUT THE FACT OF
EARLY IDENTIFICATION OF RISK
AND INTERVENTION. WE CAN REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN PLACED
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION BY UP TO
SEVENTY PERCENT. THE EVIDENCE
I'M DYSLEXIC KEEPS GROWING AT
THE WAIT. TO FAIL MODEL PERCENT.
IN FOR VISION AND HEARING BUT
NOT FOR RISK OF THE- AND THIS
NEEDS TO CHANGE PLEASE VOTE YES
ON SB TWO THIRTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEN NONE WE WILL GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT WE WILL
TAKE THE FIRST FIFTEEN IN
SUPPORT. AND REACH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- BEFORE WE BEGAN
OKAY THANK YOU. PARDON ME IF
SOMEBODY HAS HER PHONE LINE
OPEN PLEASE YOU SHOULD BE
PUNISHED. THANK YOU OKAY WE
WILL NOW GO TO. BLIND ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. FIND. ONE THIRTY
FOUR. ONE ONE THIRTY FOUR YEAR
WANTED TO OPEN. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON THE LINE FORTY FOUR.
HELLO PLEASE PRESS ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON ACTUALLY IN A COLD
YOU DON'T WANT ME TO THINK NOW
THAT OUR ACT. COULD OUR NEXT
PERSON SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE
ZERO IS OPEN. PRICE EIGHT YOU
WOULD ACCEPT NEEDS WILL BE
CALIFORNIA YEAH I SUPPORTED
EACH BUILDING A STUDENTS
MEETING IDENTIFICATION RECEIVED
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. PINE. FIFTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING HE TOOK A
LOOK AT THE KEY LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT PARENT
I SUPPORT SB THIRTY SEVEN AS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
FIVE. HELLO. ONE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS CHRISTY DENNIS I AM
THE PARENT OF TWO CHILDREN WITH
DYSLEXIA AND I RESIDE IN
PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT THE BILL
AS AMENDED THANK YOU. ONE ONE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS RANI GLICKMAN
AND I'M A TEACHER WITH THE
CENTER OF THE CITY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND A PARENT OF A
CHILD WITH DYSLEXIA I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB TWO THREE
SEVEN. YOU. PINE. FORTY EIGHT.
PINE FORTY ACRE LINES OPEN.
CALIFORNIA GUIDELINES WORKERS
MEMBER IMPORTANT. THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE ZERO ONE. HELLO MY
NAME IS OR YOU CAN BE ONLINE
ARE IMPAIR THAT FACULTY
ASSOCIATION POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE HERE AT DE ANZA
COLLEGE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME
IS MICHELLE BROWN I AM A PARENT
OF A CHILD WITH DYSLEXIA IN
KELSEYVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO THREE
SEVEN AS AMENDED. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY KILLED. MICHELLE
PERRY SPECIAL EDUCATION
ADVOCATE MY SUPPORT SB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE ONE SIXTY. HELLO MY
NAME IS GLENDA CARVALHO THOU
INTERNAL VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND
THE PARENT OF A NINE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER WITH DYSLEXIA AND I
SUPPOR AT THE TWO THIRTY SEVEN
AT AN END THANK YOU. SAID THE-
ONE ONE SIXTY FOUR. HELLO MY
NAME IS GARY STEINBERG AND IN
CHINO CALIFORNIA I'M THE FATHER
OF AN ADULT SHARKS SIX SONS AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SPEAK TO
THIRTY SEVEN AS A MANAGE IT'S
CRUCIAL TO IDENTIFY CHILDREN
VERY EARLY WITH THIS PROBLEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND
FORTY. HI MY NAME IS KIM
MITCHELL FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH
AND I AM THE PARENT OF A NINE
YEAR OLD SON WITH DYSLEXIA AND
I SUPPORT AT FIFTY TWO THIRTY
SEVEN AS AMENDED. THANK YOU.
LINE. FIFTY GOOD MORNING GLENN
MITCHELL FROM PASADENA
CALIFORNIA EARNED A THREE
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN NONE OF
THEM HAVE DYSLEXIA BUT WILL
BENEFIT HAS ALSO TO WILL FROM
THE SUPREME SCREENING I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THAT WAS
OUR FOURTEEN BY NUMBER ONE. ONE
MORE THANK YOU. LINE. ONE FORTY
SEVEN. ONE FORTY SEVEN. PARDON
ME ONE SEVENTY FOUR I APOLOGIZE.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR YES MA'AM
THAT'S YOU- I'M CALLING IS THE
WIFE OF AN EDUCATOR MOTHER OF
FOUR CHILDREN I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BUT I'M AGAINST YOU
LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT AND I'M
AGAINST DOCTOR PAN ONLY LEAVING
THE COMMITTEES ALIGNED HE RUNS
A LINE WHERE DOES HE- MISTER
MODERATOR GOING. FOR FORWARD WE
HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS BEING
BELLIGERENT YOU MAY JUST CUT
THE PHONE LINE. RIGHT THOSE ARE
FIFTEEN OF FOLKS IN SUPPORT
WE'RE NOW GOING TO OPPOSITION.
AND I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE
SOMEONE ON THE LINE FOR
OPPOSITION. MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN QUEUE THEM UP. AND
GUEST SPEAKER IF YOU ARE ON THE
CONFERENCE PLEASE SPEAK NOW.
GOOD MORNING MARCUS ERRICO SAID
DHEAS REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
ALL STUDENTS INCLUDING ENGLISH
LEARNERS GETTING ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE INSTRUCTION AND
CERTAINLY STUDENTS DIAGNOSED
WITH DYSLEXIA SHOULD GET
APPROPRIATE EARLY
INTERVENTIONS. SENATE BILL TWO
THREE SEVEN DOES NOT CALL FOR
THIS IT PROPOSES ANNUALLY
SCREENING ALL STUDENTS
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH SECOND
GRADE INCLUDING STRONG READERS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF IDENTIFYING
WAYS WHETHER THEY ARE AT RISK
OF DYSLEXIA. FOR ELL STUDENTS
SCREENING KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
SECOND GRADE WILL LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS
OVER IDENTIFYING DETAILS AS
DYSLEXIC RESULTING IN THE
NARROWING OF THEIR
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM TO FOCUS
ONLY ON FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS AND
NOT IN OTHER AREAS NECESSARY.
FOR A CHOIR IN LITERACY SUCH AS
COMPREHENSIVE AN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR ELL
STUDENTS NEED TO BE INCLUDED IN
SENATE BILL TWO THREE SEVEN.
SUCH AS ANY SCREENER OR
ASSESSMENT MUST BE PROVEN TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY AND READING SKILLS.
ENGLISH LEARNERS RECEIVING
BILINGUAL INSTRUCTION MUST BE
SCREENED AND ASSESSED IN THE
TARGET LANGUAGE ONLY STUDENTS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING READERS AS
THE EVIDENCE BY TEACHER
OBSERVATION FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS GRADE LEVEL
LITERACY BENCHMARK ASSESSMENTS
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED FOR
SCREENING FOR DYSLEXIA ONCE THE
STUDENTS SCREENED THERE IS NO
NEED FOR YEARLY TESTING.
TEACHERS IF THEY ARE THE
SCREENERS WILL REQUIRE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING ON ITS
HOUSTON ADMINISTRATION
ESPECIALLY IF SCREENING ENGLISH
LEARNERS ALL COMMUNICATION TO
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING PARENTS
MUST BE IN THEIR PRIMARY
LANGUAGE. ONLY AS MUST MONITOR
AND EVALUATE THE
PROPORTIONALITY OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS ANOTHER STUDENT
SUBGROUPS IDENTIFIED AT RISK OF
DYSLEXIA IN COMPARISON TO THEIR
PERCENTAGE OF ENROLLMENT
WITHOUT THE SAFEGUARDS THAT WE
BELIEVE SENATE BILL. THREE
SEVEN CREATES AN UNEASY ALL
FIELD WHAT DOES IT. INCLUDE
LEARNERS REGARD READING AND
LATER. THESE ARE RECENT FOR
OPPOSE CENTER BILL THREE SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM WE
WILL NOW GO TO OFFICE. IN FORTY
BOTH. SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION AND TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW G TO
THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION TO.
S. B. TWO THIRTY SEVEN. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE ATTHIS TIME PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO LINE. FORTY FOUR. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS NATALIA
OTHER DENTAL PROFESSOR
NEGLECTED IT DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR EQUITY FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS AT LOYOLA MARYMOUNT
UNIVERSITY I HEAR THE CONCERNS
REGARDING ANY COMMAND EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN TO ENSURE THAT THE
PERFECT MA'AM I AM IN THE CIVIC
MA'AM JUST GET YOUR NAME IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. I DO I DO
YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO EXPLAIN NO
EVERYTHING MY NAME OKAY IN YOUR
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
PERSON PLEASE. BUYING. SIXTY
SEVEN. AND YOU KNOW AND THEN
OPPOSITION Q. SB THIRTY SEVEN-
AT THAT POINT- BILINGUAL
TEACHER AND CAMPAIGN LITERATURE
EVEN AFTER AND TEACHER
PREPARATION THEY GIVE OUT AFTER
IT THEN WHO TAKING ADVERSITY.
THANK YOU. THE NAME OF PLEASE
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANYONE
ELSE AND I'M SURE THERE IS NO
WHAT. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE YES CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU A MANAGER AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL AS
SOMEBODY WHO- SUFFERED FROM A
SLIGHT FOR WHICH IS THE- YOUNG
PERSON. AND THANK GOD FOR A
TEACHER THAT RECOGNIZE AND WAS
ABLE TO HELP. THEM TEACH IN A
DIFFERENT WAY SO THAT WERE I
WAS ABLE TO. COMPREHEND AND
READ SO I IDEA I KNOW IT'S NOT
PERFECT THERE'S SOME OPPOSITION
BUT- THIS IS DEFINITELY A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND I.
DIDN'T SPEAK ON YOUR OTHER TWO
BILLS BECAUSE I KNOW WE'RE IN A
HURRY DAY AND I ALSO.
APPRECIATE YOU BRING IN THOSE
BILLS FORWARD- OF SOMEBODY THAT
WAS ELEVEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
RIGHT NOW IS DEALING WITH THIS-
DISTANCE LEARNING IT'S- GREATLY
NEEDED SO I APPRECIATE BOTH
THOSE AND I WOULD MOVE THIS
BILL MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY TO HAVE ANY OTHER.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NINE CENTER
PORTANTINO GEORGIA CLOSE THANK
YOU- MADAM CHAIR AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY I AM CERTAINLY.
SENSITIVE TO THE- ENGLISH
LEARNER. ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
RAISED AND I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THAT. YOU KNOW WITHIN THE
BILL IT SAYS INTEREST
INSTRUMENTS THAT ARE CULTURALLY
ENGLISH LINGUISTICALLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE.
FOR STUDENTS AND I ALSO AGREE
THAT. EVERYTHING SHOULD BE
TRANSLATED- AS YOU KNOW I'VE-
PUT A BILL THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT. IT
PEAS ARE TRANSLATED INTO.
LANGUAGES SO FAMILIES- CAN KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THEIR KIDS
ALIVE SO WE'RE DEFINITELY I'M
DEFINITELY SENSITIVE THOSE
ISSUES I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION. TO
TRY TO WORK SOME OF THEM OUT WE
THINK WE'VE MADE STRIDES TO BE
SENSITIVE. WE ALSO I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE LOCAL.
FLEXIBILITY FOR DISTRICTS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE A HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS WILL DO. A DIFFERENT
APPROACH THAN THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE THAT DON'T
AND SO WE'RE REALLY WORKING
WITH THE DISTRICT BY DISTRICT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
IMPLEMENTABLE. AND THE
CHALLENGES FACING FAMILIES- TO
IDENTIFY EARLY- DYSLEXIA IS
GOING TO HAVE. AN EXPONENTIAL
BENEFIT IN THE LONG RUN- SO WE
THINK THAT SOCIAL JUSTICE
ELEMENTS. AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES WILL BE
ADDRESSED AND- HOPEFULLY MOVE
FORWARD TO TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DOLLY- MA'AM PHONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER. THREE S. B. TWO THIRTY
SEVEN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA. BY RIVERSIDE
TROUBLED BY VIRTUAL BOGUE BY
COURTESY ALL. ATTEND THE AYE
DALY. KELLY HI GLAZER HI GLAZER
HI MCGUIRE. PAN. COOLEY THAT
BELONG CALL FOR TO OUR SENATORS
THANK YOU CENTER. NEXT UP IS
SENATOR DODD WHO'S BEEN VERY
PATIENT THANK YOU SIR. SB
TWENTY BY SENATOR DODD PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FIRST I WANT TO NOTE
THAT I'LL BE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED THE
ANALYSIS AND THNK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL. SB TWENTY WILL
HELP SECURE CALFRESH BENEFITS
FOR AN ESTIMATED. ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS. NEARLY ONE IN THREE
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
FACE INCLUDED SECURITY WITH
BLACK AND HISPANIC STUDENTS
MORE THAN LIKELY- THAN OTHER
STUDENTS TO FACE FOOD
INSECURITY. IT DEPICTS ONLY
ADDED TO THE STRUGGLES HOWEVER
MANY STUDENTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
CALFRESH BENEFITS ARE SIMPLY
UNAWARE OF THEIR ELIGIBILITY SB
TWENTY WILL HELP BRIDGE THAT
GAP BY EXPANDING THE CRITERIA
FOR WHICH STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE
NOTIFICATION THAT THEY MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH. SB
TWENTY WILL REQUIRE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO DEVELOP
DEVELOP TO DEVELOP DOCUMENTS
THAT CAN BE USED BY STUDENTS
AND COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS AS
VERIFICATION THE STUDENT MEETS
THE CRITERIA. FOR EXEMPTION
FROM STUDENT ELIGIBILITY RULES
REGULATIONS. YOUR TESTIFIED
SUPPORT THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION IS KEVIN AS
LENIENT. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
WE WILL GO TO YOUR FIRST LEAD
WITNESS. THE STRUGGLING HIM
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO HEAR THOUGH STILL
AND GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THE COURT BONTA IF THE CALL
THAT WAS HELP THEM. IT COULD.
SHE DOES NOT COMPLAIN THAT
THERE ABLE TO HOLD EASIER CAN
BE QUITE RECORDS OF. SO POPULAR.
STUDENTS THAT PROPER CARE.
FIFTY ONE LINKED UP OF WHAT OF
THE QUESTION FOOTBALL TWITTER
UNDER THROUGH HER. BY MAKING
REPLICATE. OF AB ONE CHARMING.
BUT THIS COULD UPLOAD ON THE
INTERNET. TALK ABOUT THE
CREATION. AND COMBAT HI. THERE
WILL I WILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. WE WILL NOW GO TO FORTY
TWO OH THREE FOUR SUPPORT
SEEING NONE GO THROUGH TWENTY.
SEEN NONE LET'S GO TO THE LINE
FOR MODERATOR FOR CAN OPEN UP
FOR SUPPORT WITNESSES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM FOR THOSE WHO
WERE TO SPEAK CONSERVE OF COST
PLEASE ONE THEN. PRESS ONE
ZERO. WATFORD GO TO LINES.
THREE GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS
I AM NOT SURE WHAT THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION OR- THANK YOU. FIND
FORTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS THE TALLY HERNANDEZ AND
I AM A STUDENT AT PASADENA CITY
COLLEGE AND ALSO PART OF THE
LOW INCOME WE NEED FOR OUR
SCHOOL AND I FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS OF
THE DONNA CALLING ON BEHALF OF
COUNCIL FOR A STRONG AMERICA
AND MISSION READINESS INTO
COURT THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU.
BLIND SIXTEEN. IT WOULD BE
STANFORD ON BEHALF OF THE STI
YOU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BYE AND ONE NO ONE.
ARE YOU AND YOUR AND EARNED OR
I THINK. TWENTY- SHE- WELL YEAH.
THANK YOU FIND ONE ONE EIGHTIES.
HI GOOD MORNING JUST WHOSE ONLY
CRIME THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
AT THIS TIME BUT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE IMPLANTS ARE
PRETTY SHAPING AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THAT
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WHICH I SEE NONE
WILL GO TO FORTY TWO OH THREE
FOR ANY OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
LETS GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NONE MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWENTY. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR KNOWN AS SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE YES SENATOR CORTESE.
IF SIR DOLLARS WHEN THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD-
BASED ON CONVERSATIONS WITH
STUDENTS SENATE'S- IN SENATE
DISTRICT FIFTEEN INTEL CORE
COUNTY A LARGE- IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM- THIS
IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE OF THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES FOLLOWED.
ASTONISHINGLY OF COURSE BY
HOMELESSNESS IS A CLOSE SECOND-
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO COME ON AS A CO
AUTHOR. OF WITH YOUR PERMISSION
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THING AND HEARING
THEM I DID HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR GLAZERS. HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR DODD
SPECTRALLY ASPIRO VOTE THANK
YOU AND I TO WANT TO SAY THAT'S
A GREAT BILL WE HAVE LOTS OF
THINGS. TO DO BUT IT STUDENTS
ARE HUNGRY THEY CAN'T DO
ANYTHING SO THANK YOU AFTER I
KNOW YOU YOUR COULD I JUST BE
QUICK- YOU KNOW I STARTED OUT
THREE YEARS AGO AND DID FOR YOU
SEE STUDENTS AND THAT LAST.
YOUR TWO YEARS AGO. C. ISSUE
AND NOW FOLLOWING UP ON.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF THIS- IT'S
WORKING AND IN THESE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS PEOPLE ARE. REALLY
GETTING THE BENEFITS THEY NEED
THANK YOU. MUCH APPRECIATED
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR GLAZERS MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM FOR SB TWENTY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA BY. RIVER
HI- TROUBLE BOGUE. HI CHILUBA A
COURTESY. FOR TENNESSEE I.
EIGHT DALY. KELLY I. GLAZER HI
GLAZER I'D MCGUIRE PAN. THANK
YOU WILL THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU SIR DONE MEMBERS MIX UP IS-
FALLON FIVE SB TWO SIX SENATOR
SKINNER.
GOOD MORNING PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
ENACTED S. B. TWO OH SIX THE
FAIR PAY TO PLAY ACT WHICH MADE
US THE FIRST STATE TO GRANT
COLLEGE ATHLETES THE RIGHT TO
EARN MONEY FROM THEIR NAME
IMAGE AND LIKENESS. THAT BILL
JUMPSTARTED ACTION ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THIRTY STATES HAVE NOW
EITHER INTRODUCED BILLS OR
ANNOUNCED PLANS FIVE STATES
HAVE ENACTED. THIS LAW COLORADO
FLORIDA MICHIGAN NEW JERSEY IN
NEBRASKA CONGRESS IS
CONSIDERING THIS LAW AND THE N.
C. TWO AA HAS ALSO CONSIDERED
REVISING THEIR RULES AND HOUSE
PROPOSAL. WE IN DELIBERATING ON
SB TWO OH SIX BECAUSE WE WERE
THE FIRST WE DELAYED ITS START
DATE TO GIVE THE COLLEGES AN
ANTI TO AND EVERYBODY TIME. BUT
NOW BECAUSE OF OUR DELAYED
STATE START DATE AND BECAUSE
THE OTHER STATES ARE ALL GOING
TO GO INTO EFFECT BEFORE US WE
COULD PUT CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
ATHLETES AT A DISADVANTAGE.
ADDITIONALLY THE NC TWO EIGHT
OWN RULES COULD GO INTO EFFECT
BEFORE A BILL GOES INTO EFFECT
WHICH AGAIN COULD PUT OUR
ATHLETES AT A DISADVANTAGE SO
WHAT THIS BILL BEFORE YOU DOES
IS MOVES UP THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE TO WHENEVER THE NCQA ROLES
GOING TO AFFECT OR TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHICHEVER COMES
FIRST. BADS ATHLETIC REPUTATION
TO THE ATHLETES RIGHTS ADDS A
SEPARATE BUILDING COSTS TO
PROTECT OUR LAW FIRM- IN CASE
FOR COURT CHALLENGE AND ADDS A
PROVISION THAT ENSURES THAT
COLLEGE ATHLETES CAN'T BE
DENIED RIGHTS THAT OTHER
COLLEGE STUDENTS AB EXCEPT
REGARDING RECRUITMENT AND I
WOULD. HAVE MY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT HAYLEY HODSON A FORMER
STANFORD VOLLEYBALL PLAYER
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU. CAN QUEUE UP
OUR LEAD SUPPORT. HI THIS IS
HALEY HOBSON- I WAS A FORMER
ALL AMERICAN VOLLEYBALL PLAYER
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND I'M
NOW A SECOND YEAR LAW STUDENT
AT UCLA. I HAD TO RETIRE FROM
CREATIVELY BALL AFTER JUST ONE
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE SERIOUS-
BRAIN INJURY. AND IT SB TWO
AFFECTS THE FAIR PLAY TO PLAY
ACTED BENEFACTOR AT THE TIME
THAT I WAS. COOPER CREEK AND
NASTY I CUT IS LEVERAGE MY
DISABILITY AS A COLLEGE-
RECRUIT AND A COLLEGE. ATHLETE
YOU ABLE TO MAKE SOME MONEY OR
TELL MY BRAND WHICH IS NOW MORE
THAN EVER THE ERA OF SOCIAL
MEDIA- FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FORTY SUPPORT AND
SB TWO. SIX PASSING BY LED TO.
WHY CAN. AND HOBBS START A
MOVEMENT- FIVE OTHER STATES AN
SIMILAR LAWS IN THE IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO FLORIDA'S LAW THAT
GOES INTO A FACT JULY FIRST AT
YEAR. WHAT ARE TWENTY SAID IN
TO DO IS. BOB MARLEY R. AND I.
DAY SO THE- WE ARE BEHIND BUT-
BEHIND THE OTHERS. THAT ARE.
GOING TO BE LEADING THE CHARGE
WE WERE THE- TO PASS THAT'S
WHAT. AND I THINK IT IS OUR
DUTY TO KEEP UP WITH WHAT IS
GOING ON- MLK SIDE- A RIGHT
DELAYED IS A RIGHT TONIGHT AND
I THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER THAT WE SHOULD DO WE
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR ATHLETES TO
BE AN ADVANTAGE- IN THAT SPACE-
I. TWENTY SAID OF ALSO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT. IS A FOR
YEAR LAST ARE MONEY FROM OFF
LET RPG. THIS IS THAT WOULD BY
SORT OF A- AND AT THROUGHOUT
THE SHE AND THAT'S WHAT I'M-
THE- IS- I WERE DOING I WOULD
CALL ATHLETE. AND I WOULD DOING
AT. OR SOMETHING I COULD
ACTUALLY- DENOTE WHERE I PLAYED
MY SPORT AND- THE RELATIONSHIP
I HAD TO THAT UNIVERSITY AND
FUTURE BY ONE THOUSAND ATHLETES
IN ORDER TO LEVERAGE
OPPORTUNITIES SO I COULD SAY I
NEARLY HOPPED. THE STANFORD
VOLLEYBALL PLAYER AND I
SUPPORT. THE BEST. AND I THINK
THIS IS ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN IT COMES TO- MINORITY
ATHLETES AND FEMALE ATHLETES
THAT DISPEL AND BEING ABLE TO
GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO-
INVOICE BEING. ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WELL REALLY BEGAN
HELPING TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME
LIKE THIS PANDEMIC WHERE WE
HAVE- SUCH ECONOMIC ISSUES
HAPPENING ACROSS THE BOARD-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
WILL GO TO SUPPORT YOUR. ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. SEEING NONE.
OF CURTIS OF AND ROOM TWENTY
FOUR. C. NONE LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO OUR PHONE MISTER
MONTEREY CAN YOU KEEP ANYONE
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWENTY SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO. NOW GOOD I
MIGHT HAVE BEEN ONE NINETY TWO.
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
INSTRUCTORS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FORTY NINE. BY
ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M AFRAID WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO MOVE ON THE LINE FIFTY
ONE. FIND MORE MONEY COULD BE
ONE YEAR WONDERS OPEN. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO LINE. ONE SIXTY
SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS JENNY I
AM INTERESTED IN THE SAN DIEGO
AND- A REPRESENTATIVE AGAIN
I'LL I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY.
EIGHTY ONE. HELLO THIS IS ANDY
SCHWARTZ I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE PROFESSIONALCOLLEGIATE
LEAGUE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE NINETY. PARKING
NINETY YOUR WORKERS AFTER
TWELVE IN STRONG THE COURT FOR
THAT THE TWENTY FIFTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE ONE NINETY FOUR.
THIS IS REMOTE HOME A WITH THE
NATIONAL COLLEGE PLAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK COULD
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW GO TO ENSURE PARDON ME
I APOLOGIZE WE HAVE- SOME LAST
MINUTE ENTRIES HERE PARDON ME
NO ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MONNING MY NAME IS CAN WE
WILL AND THE NINETY SEVEN.
UNCLE HE'S TALKING. I WANT TO
JOB AND THE JOB JACK WE GET ON
CALLING DEVOID AND PASSED WHAT
SB TWENTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. PINE WHEN SO. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR BOB RON RAPP ON
OF THE- FACULTY S. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
THE TELEPHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE ON THE LINE.
IF ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS. ONE
ZERO. MADAM CHAIR NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
OVER A BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS. AT THE END OF
THE BILL ALL RIGHT SEEING THAT
WE HAVE A MOTION THE CENTER
GLAZER CENTER SKINNER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- CHAIR AND- JUST REFERENCE
MY OF OUR NEW COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN JOSE THAT IT WAS THE THAT
STUDENT ATHLETES TOMMIE SMITH
AND JOHN CARLOS WHO WERE SOME
OF THE FIRST STUDENT ATHLETES
TO BRING ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE. THAT WAS MANY MANY MANY
YEARS AGO SO VERY VERY HAPPY
THAT CALIFORNIA'S MOVING
FORWARD AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND- WOULD JUST
INDICATE THAT AT SOME POINT WE
MAY ADD DEPEND IS SHOWING-
DEPENDING ON HOW. THE IF THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED IN THE SAME
WAY THAT TWO OH SIX WE MAY ADD
THE URGENCY CLAUSE SIR WOULD GO
INTO EFFECT ON JULY ONE WHICH
WOULD THEN ALIGN IT TO
FLORIDA'S BUT WE ARE STILL
WORKING THAT OUT SO THANK YOU
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR SKINNER
BUT WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
GLAZER MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM FIVE SB
TWENTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY LEYVA HI
IF I BUY PHOTO ABOVE. CORTESE
ALL RIGHT WHATEVER THE A HIGH
DALY GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN. BELIEVE DOUBLE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER NEXT UP IS SENATOR TO
RAZA WITH. SB. THREE THIRTY.
SILVERADO PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THE MEDICARE AND MEMBERS
THE MADAM CHAIR WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
PROPOSED. AMENDMENTS AS
REFLECTED ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS. THANK YOU 55% OF LA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE HOUSING INSECURITY
THE LACK OF ACCESS TO HOUSING
PRECLUDES MANY OF CALIFORNIANS
FROM HIGHER EDUCATION. SB THREE
THIRTY GIVES CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ESSENTIAL
TOOLS TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS FACING BOTH THE STUDENTS
AND EMPLOYEES OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ACROSS THE STATE.
PRESENT PRESENTLY. SOME
COMMUNITY COLLEGES POSSESS
EITHER AMUSE REAL PROPERTY OR
FACILITIES THAT HAVE BECOME TOO
FINANCIALLY BURDENSOME TO
OPERATE SB THREE THIRTY GIVES
CALIFORNIA COMEY COLLEGES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPURPOSE SUCH
UNUSED SPACE INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS. SB THREE
THIRTY AUTHORIZES THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO ENTER INTO
LEASES OR AGREEMENTS WITH
PRIVATE ENTITIES OR NOT PROFITS
FOR JOINT OCCUPANCY A REAL
PROPERTY AND BUILDINGS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS
OR EMPLOYEES OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. THE BILL
EXTENDS EXISTING FIVE YEAR
LEASE. OR AGREEMENT LIMITATION
TO A TERM NOT TO EXCEED SIXTY
SIX YEARS SO LONG AS THE JOINT
OCCUPANCY LEASE AN AGREEMENT IS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS OR EMPLOYEES. FINALLY
THE MEASURE AUTHORIZES THE
GOVERNING BOARD OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO LEASE REAL
PROPERTY FOR LESS THAN FAIR
RENTAL VALUE TO AN ENTITY IF
THAT ENTITY INTENDS TO ENTER
INTO A LEASE AGREEMENT. FOR
JOINT OCCUPANCY AND IS USED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL ARE
PERMISSIVE AND PROVIDE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT THE
MEANS TO ENTER INTO JOINT
OCCUPANCY AGREEMENTS ONLY IF
SUCH AN AGREEMENT PROVIDES A
POSITIVE SOLUTION TO THESE
NEEDS. CALIFORNIANS THE MIDST
OF A CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS CANNOT
SERVE THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS IF THE STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO EVEN BASIC NEEDS
WE WILL CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON THESE CAMPUSES THE
BILL WAS SPONSORED BY THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. MY WITNESS TODAY WILL
BE ALEX ALANIZ WHO IS APPEARING
ON BEHALF OF THE LA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND IS
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
RAZA. LISA PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN- CHARWOMAN
LEYVA AND SENATORS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM ALEX CELANESE.
THE LOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT I WANT TO EXPRESS
ELLIE CCD STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE THIRTY. HI THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE GIVE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ESSENTIAL
TOOLS TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS FACING BOTH STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES OF JUNIOR COLLEGES
ACROSS THE STATE. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS TO ENTER INTO LEASES
OR AGREEMENTS WITH PRIVATE
ENTITIES FOR JOINT OCCUPANCY OF
REAL PROPERTY AND BUILDINGS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS.
LOUISE OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. LOS ANGELES COUNTY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IS PROUD TO
HAVE ONE OF THE LARGEST AND
MOST DIVERSE STUDENT BODIES
WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS ENROLLED EACH
YEAR. BUT DIDN'T COME FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE BRINGING
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCES
INCLUDING APPROXIMATELY. TEN
THOUSAND ROLLED IN COLLEGE
PROMISED. STUDENTS REPRESENTING
THE FIRST TO EVER GO TO COLLEGE
STUDENTS RETURNING FOR A SECOND
CHANCE. NEARLY 50% OF ALLEY CCD
STUDENTS ARE BETWEEN THE AGES
OF TWENTY AND THIRTY FOUR. THIS
STUDENT GROUP IS MORE
VULNERABLE TO ACADEMIC STARTS
AND STOPS AND IT NEED TO BE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES LACC
OFFERS THE MOST. TAKING THE
CRITICAL STEP TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL CAN BE EASILY DERAILED
BECAUSE OF A CAR ISSUE WORK
SCHEDULE THE CONFLICTS WITH THE
CLASS OR RENT INCREASE. JANUARY
THIS YEAR RENTAL LOS ANGELES
WERE ON AVERAGE TWO THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
DOLLARS. ONLY 1% OF RENTAL
TODAY ARE BETWEEN SEVEN HUNDRED
AND ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS. OVER
ONE THIRD OF RENTERS IN LA PAID
MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR MONTHLY
INCOME TO RENT. THIS BILL GIVES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ENTER INTO A
JOINT OCCUPANCY PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE RESPONSIBLE THIRD
PARTY DEVELOPER. RICHARD OUR
COMMON GOAL OF PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE SUBSIDIZED RENTAL
UNITS. THE COLLEGE DISTRICT
WOULD PROVIDE THE LAND AND
RETAIN ALL OF THE PROTECTIONS
CURRENTLY OFFERED BY STATUTE.
BUT IF THE PARTNERSHIP IS TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
MAKE AN EXCEPTION FOR RECORDING
THE HIGHEST MONETARY RATE OF
RETURN. BUT PROVIDING THE LAND
AT A NOMINAL COST. YOU TO
COLLEGE DISTRICTS CAN HELP
CONTROL ONE FACTOR OF THE MANY
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE EVER
INCREASING COST TO BUILD IN
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
TURNER CENTER FOR HOUSING
INNOVATION AT UC BERKELEY. THE
COST TO BUILD ONE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNIT COST ALMOST COST
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. OSTERLAND IS ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE OVERALL
DEVELOPMENT COSTS. IS THE COST
OF HOUSING FOR EMPLOYEES AND
STUDENTS CAN LEVY A HOUSING AND
SECURITY BURDENS. YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I'M RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU VOTE FOR- SB THREE THIRTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL GO TO
FORTY TWO OR THREE FOUR
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
TWENTY FOUR FOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT TWENTY FORTY THING NO
ONE WILL NOT GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE IN QUEUE TO
SUPPORT SB THREE THIRTY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE
DO HAVE- PARTICIPANT TO SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE. TWENTY
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NOT BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY.
NINETEEN GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MY AUNT'S BAKER IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THIRTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIND. ONE NINETY
NINE. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE NO. ONE GOOD AFTERNOON.
IN THE BAY AREA PART OF THE
ESTATE TAX ID STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE- THANK YOU THANK
YOU. YEAH LINE. ONE NINETY SIX.
GOOD MORNING TERM MEMBERS TO
THE INTERNET COMES ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. BY.
TWO OH ONE. HI GOOD MORNING I'M
I'M ASIAN TRANSNATIONAL'S
DILLON AT THE END OF COLLEGE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND.
ONE NINETY FIVE. ONE ONE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN FACT.
ONLY A NIGHT BEFORE THANK YOU.
I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. WHO WISHES TO SPEAK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO TO
FORTY TWO OH THREE FOR ANYONE
OPPOSING THE BILL FACING NINE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NONE MR OFFERED TO HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE- WHO WISHES
TO OPPOSE THE BILL. AND AGAIN
IF ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
BECAUSE TIME. SURE WE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE PERSON WHO SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU BEST MOMENT. AND THE. WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE. TWO
HUNDRED. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RICHARD MARCUSSEN FOR
THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION- WEEK
IS NOT OPPOSED TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS HOWEVER THERE IS A
PROVISION IN THE BILL AS
AMENDED THAT CREATES A LOOPHOLE
THAT ALLOWS SOME CONTRACTORS TO
AVOID STATE ENFORCEMENT OF THE
PUBLIC CONTRACTS CODE. THAT
MANDATES THE USE OF A SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE WE
BELIEVE THE BILL SHOULD BE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD. WITH
EQUITABLE APPLICATION OF THIS
LAW TO ALL CONTRACTORS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. CENTER
GLAZER. THANK YOU CARE LEYVA-
SENATOR RAZA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AYE
AYE SUPPORT TO EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE WITH-
ALL ALL GOOD REASONS. JUST A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ONE
QUESTION ONE CLARIFICATION. ON
ON THE AFFORDABLE SIDE IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU ARE
TAKING THE- THE RECOMMEND
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE ANALYSIS
ABOUT DEFINING AFFORDABLE SETH
YES. YEAH THAT'S GREAT THANK
YOU FOR DOING THAT. BOB THEN
THE SECOND ISSUE IS- YOU KNOW
ON A TYPICAL- HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT THAT THEY WOULD BE
REVIEWED- IN A PUBLIC PROCESS
LOCALLY. ANARCHY HEARINGS AND
THE LIKE THAT WOULD HAPPEN AND
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. YOU KNOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES HERE TO DO THESE
THINGS WITHOUT THAT SAME- YEAH
IT ENGAGEMENT- FOR THE
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES THAT
THEY'RE DOING AND THIS IS IT
THIS IS A CHANGE THIS IS A-
PROVIDING HOUSING AND- I'M
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
THE ISSUE OF LOCAL INPUT AND
HOW WE CAN BE SURE THAT- CANNOT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ISRAEL IS
REACHING OUT AND ENGAGING- DID
THAT DID YOU SPEAK OF IT AT ALL
IN THIS BILL IN TERMS OF THE
ABILITY TO WORK TO ENSURE THAT
THAT. THAT IS. WHAT HAPPENS. I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT.
UNDER BUT I WILL GLADLY LOOK
INTO IT- I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
THERE OUGHT TO BE. THIS IS A
WHOLE DIFFERENT. KIND OF
DEVELOPMENT THAN WHAT I THINK
PEOPLE EXPECT SO I WILL
ABSOLUTELY LOOK INTO IT. BUT I
THINK I DO THAT IN YOUR BILL IS
JUST AN EXACT RIGHT DIRECTION
AND- I DO KNOW IN MY DISTRICT
HAVE THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THEY'RE ALL DAY IN
DIFFERENT PLACES YOU KNOW ONES
UP ON A HILL. HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT THERE'S JUST NOT
GOING TO BE AN ISSUE ANOTHER
ONE SITS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND- YOU KNOW
AGAIN TYPICALLY THE NEIGHBORS
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO ENGAGE WITH
THE LOCAL OFFICIALS AND THEY
HAVE THE LOCAL HEARINGS AND
THAT ALL GETS CIRCUMVENTED SITE
I REALLY APPRECIATE IF YOU
COULD TAKE JUST. CONSIDER SOME
THINGS YOU CAN DO IN THE BILL
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS SOME
ENGAGEMENT A PUBLIC HEARING-
CONCERT A CONSULTATION OF- THE
REQUIREMENT OF SOME KIND NAUTIC
NECESSARILY GIVE AUTHORITY AWAY
I APPRECIATE. WHY THAT CREATES
PROBLEMS BUT- WE ONCE. PLANNING
WE WANT- TO FEEL INVOLVED AND
START OUT OF TRYING TO FIND
THAT BALANCE HAS BEEN ARE
CHALLENGING HOUSING FOR A
WHILE. AND YOU'RE NOW IN THAT
SPACE SO. I'D LOVE TO GET YOUR-
ENGAGEMENT THERE AND IF I CAN
HELP WITH THAT I APPRECIATE
YOUR- WORK ON IT. GREAT GREAT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR. I
DON'T KNOW IF MR ELENI'S HAS
ANY OTHER THOUGHTS OF THE
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT. THE ISSUE
THAT SENATOR HAS BRACED. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS. ALSO
JUST WE'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
YOUR SOCKS STAFF CENTER GLAZER
ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE
YESTERDAY- AND WE'RE LOOKING
INTO IT BUT- JUST FROM WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND. THE BILL DOES THE
MAN JUSTICE ONE SECTION
RELATING TO JOINT OCCUPANCY
THEN THE PROFESSOR- IN NO WAY I
DON'T THINK IT WAS AN ATTEMPT
TO CIRCUMVENT ANY KIND OF LOCAL
PERMITTING PROCESS OR ANY KIND
OF PUBLIC HEARINGS. RESPECT TO
NEW DEVELOPMENT. DOUBLED WILL
DO A DEEPER DIVE IN THAT JUST
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO. I'VE
BEEN COMING LOCAL. THANK YOU
GREAT COULD IT I COULD USE THAT
THING YOU FOR THAT. AB A LOOK
AT. IT MEANT TO DIVIDE MY POINT
IS NOT A CERTAIN THE SETS
CONSENT THE OF THE- OF ANY PER
I AYE. I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE
THE OBLIGATION. UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW. TO DO THAT SO I
DON'T THINK THAT YOU'RE WORKING
AROUND THAT I'M SAYING THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOW DOING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT ON THE
CAMPUS YOU STILL FIT IN A
SECTION OF THE LAW THAT DOESN'T
REQUIRE. AN ENGAGEMENT OF ANY
KIND- AND SO I I'D WELCOME.
BABY THAT MAKE IT MORE
INFORMATION THAT MAY BE SHOWS
THAT THAT'S NOT TRUE THAT THERE
ARE PLACES IN WHICH THEY MUST
AND THAT'S GREAT. AND AYE I'LL
AYE THE FOURTEENTH EDUCATED ON
THAT BUT IF THERE IS NOT I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE THE IT A-
AN EXAMINATION OF HOW WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR THAT SO EVERYBODY'S
WORKING SMARTLY TOGETHER THANK
YOU I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH
YOU ON THE POINT THAT. THAT
YOU'RE MAKING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANYTHING ELSE FROM OUR
MEMBERS SEEING NONE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER DRAWS SO.
THANK YOU MANAGER JUST ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR GLAZER MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ADAM NINE
SB THREE THIRTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA BY. LEVI TROUBLE BOGE
COURTESY FIVE BECAUSE THE AYE
DALY. GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAM. THANK BELIEVE THAT
BILL ON ON CALL THINKCENTRE
THANK YOU MANAGER MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT NEXT TO US SENATOR
GLAZERS WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
AND PRESENT FROM YOUR SEAT. ALL
RIGHT THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TO S. B.
TWENTY TWO ON THE THINK THE
CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS BILL.
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE A
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR BOND ON
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO DOLLARS.
FOR FACILITIES AFTER K. THROUGH
TWELVE THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION. SPECIFICALLY THE
BOND INCLUDES NINE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR PRESCHOOL THROUGH
EIGHTH GRADE TWELVE TWO BILLION
EACH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE LAST K. THROUGH
TWELVE THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION
BOND PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX. HOWEVER BY TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE ALL THESE FUNDS WERE THE
SENSUALLY EXHAUSTED. DESPONDENT
CRITICAL FOR BRINGING ALL OF
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS- K. TO
TWELVE THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
AND ENSURING OUR CHILDREN HAVE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER IN A SAFE
PLACE TO LEARN. THE PANDEMIC
HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
SAFE SCHOOL AND CAMPUS
FACILITIES THAT PROTECT THE-HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN AND
STAFF. MANY SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT BUILDING SPACE TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL AND STATE
RE OPENING GUIDELINES. OR ON
SMALLER CLASS SIZES. THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT CONSTRUCTION
UPGRADES AND REPAIRS THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR LARGER CLASSROOMS
IMPROVED VENTILATION SYSTEMS.
AND REDUCING THE RISK OF
TRANSMISSION AND SHARED SPACES.
ACCORDING TO. THE P. P. I. C.
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THE STATE
SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD. AND
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN IT WOULD
COST OVER A HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO MODERNIZE
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES. IN THE
NEXT DECADE. WE NEED TO DO OUR
BEST FOR OUR STUDENTS- WE DID
HAVE A DISAPPOINTING LOSS IN
THE LAST ELECTION HONEST ON A
BLIND I THINK IT'S A- IT'S THE
RARE EXCEPTION FOR UNDER UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES. I WAS PLEASED TO
SEE THAT- I THINK ALMOST SIXTY
A LOCAL SCHOOL BOND MEASURES
PASSED IN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION. AT THIS BILL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU- IS- A AN EXTENSION
OF THE NECK OF THE COMPROMISES
THAT OCCURRED FOR THE- MEASURE
LAST YEAR AND- I KNOW THAT-
THERE'S STILL MORE
CONVERSATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
TO BE HAD WITH THE ARE ABLE.
LEADER IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR- TO FASHION THIS IN A
WAY THAT- IS A RESPONSIVE TO
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED.
AND SO FOR ME THIS IS JUST THE
FIRST STEP OF THE IN THAT
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD IT
ALLOWS THE SENATE TO STAND UP
FOR THE IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS
WE WANT TO SEE OUR SCHOOLS AND
UNIVERSITIES. I WANTED TO
TECNOLOGIA- CENTER REQUIRES A
CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE- AND
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THAT TODAY WE
HAVE JASON MURPHY. FROM. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HERE
TO TESTIFY. THINKCENTRE GOING.
MR MORE PLEASE FOR WHEN YOU'RE-
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DATE AMERICA ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ARE PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY TWO
THE PUBLIC PRESCHOOL K. TWELVE
AND COLLEGE HELPED SHAPE THE
BOND ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
AS THE SENATOR NOTED- IT HAS
BEEN OVER FIFTEEN YEARS AND-
PROP. ONE D. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX WHEN- CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS
LIKE YOU SEE IF THE IF YOU WERE
ABLE TO ENJOY- CAL POLY BOND
FUND FOR EDUCATION AND SO WHAT
I'M WE'RE EAGER TO GET UP AND
GET BACK ON TRACK HOPEFULLY.
WITH THIS- BOND ACTOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- WITH GUARDS TO THE
USED TO BE- I WOULD JUST
MENTION THAT WE HAVE TO GET
AGAINST LONG TERM CAPITAL
NEEDS- MORE THAN HALF. OF OUR
EXISTING BUILDINGS ARE OVER
THIRTY YEARS OLD AND OUR
CAPITAL FINANCIAL PLAN FROM
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
SIX IN FIVE MORE THAN A BILLION
IN UNMET NEED WITH REGARDS TO
OUR FACILITIES WE BELIEVE THAT
THE- THE PROCEEDS FROM THIS
POTENTIAL BOND WOULD GO SIT
THAT WAY TOWARDS PROVIDING FOR
THE FIRE LIFE AND BY THE STATE
THE- PROJECTS THAT WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH AS WELL AS PROVIDE
FOR THE MODERNIZATION AND
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW FACILITIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. THE GROWING
TECHNOLOGY AND SPACE NEEDS FOR
STUDENTS SO INCLUDING AGAIN
WHAT THINK THE BETTER COPING
SUPPORT BILLBOARD AND- GLAD TO
BE IN TRANSPORT THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO TO
SUPPORT HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
SUPPORT AND ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEN NONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE TELEPHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATED WE HAVE. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT ON THE LINES. THANK YOU
MADAM. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT THIS TIME PLEASE. ONE
ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WERE
TO SPEAK CONSERVE. PEOPLE OF
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH THIS.
SO SUPPORT THE BILL WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY NINE.
CASH GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER FROM THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JENNIFER BAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITY
COALITION WE SUPPORT THE
MEASURE WATER SHOULD NEVER BE
OUT THERE WILLING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU FIND
ONE THE OLD ONE. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS ON YOUR BILL PENN THE
ALL ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY.
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE
INDIAN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE. TWO THIRTEEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
SURELY THAT ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWENTY CAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BY. TWO OH FIVE. BY TO A FIVE
YEAR ONE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS THIS IS INTERNET
AND AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN ¡ONG
SUPPORT OF UP TO TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PINE. ONE
TWO ELEVEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IN THE DEAL WITH A
COALITION OF ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE TWO OH FOUR.
ERIC POCKET WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY UP TO CANCER I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU CAN
SENATORS TYLER'S TIRELESS
EFFORT IN THIS ARENA THE CSU IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
TWO. THANK YOU. BY TWO FIFTEEN.
GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
ON BEHALF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REPORT.
THANK YOU BYE. TWO SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS. OR THANK YOU. AND
FINAL CALL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. ADAM CHAIR NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION SO WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY FOR
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE BRING
IT BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANYONE IN Q. TO OPPOSE. SB TWO
TWO. SURE WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
ONE NOT A CALLER WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK ALL RIGHT ONE MOMENT
PLACE. WE'RE GOING GO TO LINE.
TWO HUNDRED. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION FOR THE PLUMBING
HEATING COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA LIKE PROP THIRTEEN
WHICH WAS DEFEATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS SB TWENTY TWO
INCLUDES A PROVISION THAT
PRIORITIZES PROJECTS ASSOCIATED
WITH PRACTICAL LABOR GRIEVANCE.
PUTS RURAL AND SMALL DISTRICTS
AT A DISTINCT DISADVANTAGE FOR
SCHOOL FUNDING. RESHOOT THAT
SENATOR INDICATES THAT THIS IS
A WORK IN PROCESS. THIS
PROVISION WE BELIEVE. HELPED
CONVINCE VOTERS TO DEFEAT PROP
THIRTEEN AND SHOULD BE REMOVED
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION PINE. YES
LINE TWO ZERO NINE YOUR NAME N.
OPPOSITION PLEASE HI GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MATALIN
COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA WELL
WE DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE DO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS AND
ARE WORKING WITH DOCTOR AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'M
SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WOULD
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER CORTESE. YOUR
SOONER GLAZER I'M I'M HAPPY TO-
SUPPORT THE BILL- JUST WANT TO
PUT A CONCERN OUT THERE AND I
APPRECIATED YOUR REFERENCE TO
THIS BEING THE FIRST STEP IN A-
A LONGER. SERIES OF DISCUSSIONS
AND PERHAPS NEGOTIATIONS I
WOULD ASSUME BUT- AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE FORMULA WOULD
ULTIMATELY BE APPLIED IF WE'RE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO SEE THIS
COME TO FRUITION- BUT I KNOW
FROM MY- A PAST EXPERIENCE- IN
THE WORLD OF SCHOOL BOARDS AND-
THAT THE FUNDING FOR. SOME
ITEMS- NOT WILL WE WOULD DESIRE
THEM TO BE A PARTICULARLY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I
WOULD. HOPE THAT YOU TRY TO.
ASSERT SOME SORT OF ONGOING
JURISDICTION OVER- OVER THINGS
LIKE GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY- WITH
THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL AT WHATEVER THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IS. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS R QUESTIONS. FEDERAL
TROUBLED- SENATOR GLAZERS THE
ONLY CONCERN I HAVE HERE WELL
MAJOR CONCERN IS THE- ECONOMIC-
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE LIVING
IN RIGHT NOW. AND THE-
INCREASES OF THE TAXES FROM ONE
POINT TWO FIVE TWO TWO POINT
ZERO OR TWO PART 2% OR TWO AND
A HALF 24% IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. IS OF GRAVE
CONCERN TO ME- IN LIGHT OF WHAT
WE ARE PROJECTED TO SEE IN THE
NEXT TWO THREE FOUR YEARS IN
OUR ECONOMY. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY WILL NOT BE THE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
CENTER GLAZER WHICH I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TO
SPEAK TO THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE. TO THE SENATOR FROM
SAN JOSE I SHARE. HIS DESIRE
FOR GEOGRAPHIC BALANCE OF THE
KEYS HEARD ME SAY THAT AND
OTHER TOPICS IN OTHER FORMS-
AND- IN THE ANALYSIS IT DOES
DEFINE. THAT KIND OF THE- THAT
HOW HOW THE APPLICATIONS ARE
PRIORITIZE IT THAT IS NOT ONE
OF THE ELEMENTS- WE DO HAVE
SOME REPRESENTATION ON THAT THE
COMMITTEE THAT. MAKES THESE
DECISIONS BUT I AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOUR NOTE AND- I
WOULD LIKE TO FIND THAT BALANCE
IT IN- IN THESE ALLOCATIONS.
AND SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'LL
BE SENSITIVE TO GOING FORWARD
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY- ENDED THE SENATOR FROM
THE INLAND EMPIRE. THE ONLY
THING I WOULD NOTE- ABOUT THE-
THE CEILING BEING RACES THAT
THAT WOULD ONLY OCCUR WHERE THE
VOTERS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES TO
VOTE TO ACTUALLY- AGO GOT RAISE
THEIR TAXES. SO WHILE IT
PROVIDES AN ALLOWANCE IT DOES
IT WOULD CREATE ANY REQUIREMENT
OR OBLIGATION. AND SO I WOULD
SAY THAT- WELL I APPRECIATE
YOUR TAX SENSITIVITY I SHARE
THAT IN MANY WAYS- BUT THAT
THIS WOULD STILL BE I REMAIN I
LOCAL CHOICE ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANTED THEIR TAXES TO
GO UP. AND THAT THAT THAT IS
NOT AFFECTED BY THIS BILL
SIMPLY IT SAYS THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS AND- AND- AND
REVIEWING THE MATTER MAY BE
GOING FORWARD. WITH THAT
MEMBERS. FOR TOO LONG WE'VE
ALLOWED OUR CLASS. ARE LAW. OUR
RESEARCH LAW. AT OUR SCHOOL TO
FOR INTO JUST. THIS BOTTLE
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENT.
IN OUR EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER HIGH VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR CORTESE MA'AM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE TEN SB TWENTY TWO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
RE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. LEYVA
BY. THE V<c.cyan>- CHAU A BOAT. NO</c>
THE TROUBLE NO. PARTISI CORTEZ
THE AYE DALY. TELL NOT VOTING.
GLAZER HI GLAZER MCGUIRE M. I
AM I THINK YOU WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL SAID DOLLY BEFORE
WE TO YOUR BILL WHICH YOU CAN
PRESENT FROM YOUR SEAT I'M JUST
GOING TO REVIEW THE CALL IN
INSTRUCTIONS ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PUBLIC KNOWS
HOW TO CALL IN FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
ANNALYNNE OUTSIDE NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL
REMOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TWO DOT ONE THEN ZERO. UP FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND PLEASE WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
AWAITING QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTED AND YOU WERE NOT
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
OVERREACH ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THOROUGHLY
PLEASE BEGIN WITH SB TWO
SEVENTEEN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
FIRST WANT TO START OUT WITH
THEM BELOW HISTORY ABOUT THIS
BILL. I WAS A CO AUTHOR OF A
FEW YEARS AGO AND YOU OFFERED
SOME AMENDMENTS AND I BELIEVE
THE BILL WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GET OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND SO. FIRST OFF I WANNA SAY I
TOOK THOSE AMENDMENTS AND I'VE
WORKED WITH YOU CLOSELY AND SO
ALL THIS TO IT READ A STATEMENT
HERE AND THEN- MAYBE CLOSE WITH
SOME OTHER COMMENTS- THANK YOU.
SB TWO SEVENTEEN IS A VERY
SIMPLE BILL THAT REQUIRES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO POST THEIR
SEX EDUCATION SEX ED CURRICULUM
ONLINE IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGE FOR
ENGLISH THIS. IS A SECOND
LANGUAGE YES FAMILIES. GIVEN
THE CURRENT DISTANCE LEARNING
EDUCATION SYSTEM EVEN WITH THE
RECENT PLAN FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
OPEN. PAIRS CANNOT PHYSICALLY
VISIT THE SCHOOL TO ACQUIRE
MATERIALS THAT WILL BE TAUGHT
TO THEIR CHILDREN. SECTION FIVE
ONE THREE NINE EIGHT B. AND ONE
OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH
ACT REQUIRES THAT PARENTS. BE
NOTIFIED. THE MATERIAL IS
AVAILABLE FOR INSPECTION GIVEN
THE- THAT WE ARE IN THE COLD
AIR WITH DISTANCE LEARNING
PARENTS CANNOT PHYSICALLY GO TO
THE CAMPUS. TO THE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO INSPECT MATERIALS ARE.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE CURRENT
LAW. THIS TO INTERNET BASED
DISTANCE LEARNING WILL PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SCHOOLS TO
GET PARENTS MORE ENGAGED IN
THEIR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION AND
THIS BILL HELPS FURTHER THAT
GOAL. SCHOOLS POST OR PROVIDE
OR PROVIDE PARENTS WITH
NUMEROUS OTHER CURRICULAR
MATERIALS SO THAT IS WHY THIS
MATERIAL IS. NEEDED I'VE HAD A
GREAT CONVERSATION WITH A
CHAIR- THAT WE SHOULD NOT THIS
BILL HAD TERRIBLE PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT SEVERAL PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION WAS A LOT OF
TESTIMONY- THAT WE SHOULD JUST
DO GOOD POLICY FOR KIDS ALSO
JUST THE OTHER DAY I WAS
TALKING TO DOCTOR PAN. AND HE
TOLD ME ABOUT A TIME THAT A
TEACHER'S SOURCED INFORMATION
FROM AN OPINION WEBSITE INSTEAD
OF A CREDIBLE FACT BASED SITE.
THIS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
WHY WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
PREVENT. TO ENCOURAGING
FRIENDLY GAUGE AND ADDS IN
EDUCATION. WE'RE ALL DOING THAT
WE ARE WE ARE ALL HERE WE- WE
ARE ALL DOING HERE TO ENSURE
THE PARENTS CAN BE ENGAGE AT A
LEVEL. THEY CHOOSE IN THEIR
CHILD'S EDUCATION. TO WRAP IT
UP- I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD TRANSPARENCY BILL I- I
BELIEVE THAT I'LL BE WORKING ON
THIS BILL IF WE DON'T GET ON
THIS COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT I'VE
TALKED TO MOST OF. THE SENATORS
ON THE PANEL AND I KNOW THAT
THIS IS- IN A DIFFERENT TIME SO
I JUST WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I'D
BE BACK HAPPY TO TAKE A- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR DOLLY. WE
HAVE NO LEAD SUPPORT SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO SUPPORT HEARING
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING
NONE. WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING THEM. WE WILL GO
TO THE MODERATOR AND ASK FOR
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT. SB TWO
SEVENTEEN. SH SH SH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF TO THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. NOW GO TO LINE TWO
POINT NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JERRY MEMBERS SIR JACK WALKER
WITH THE GLOBAL GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE CHURCH OF JESUS CHRIST.
ARE YOU SAYING IT'S A QUARTER
THE BILL IN THE I MAY TAKE A
COUPLE MINUTES. ANOTHER CHAIR
IN. NO WE UP WITH THAT NO HE'S-
NOT JUST NAME IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BUT IT. FIND ONE
OF SEVEN. GREG BIRD CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY NINE.
HERSHA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO.
I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE WHO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. MANAGER ASK QUESTIONS.
YES I WOULD ASK A QUESTION OF
ONE OF THE WITNESSES SO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY CAN BE NOTIFIED
SO THEY COULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
ME TO ASK THE QUESTION THE IT
WAS TO THE XIN WITNESS YES I
DON'T KNOW SUPPORT WITNESS THAT
WAS JUDGE JACK LAHKO OKAY I
WANTED TO ASK HIM QUESTIONS WE
COULD ASK THE STAY ON THE LINE.
VERY GOOD SIR I HOPE YOU HEARD
THAT PLEASE STAY ON THE LINE
THANK YOU. OKAY WE WILL NOW GO
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO
FOLKS IDENTIFIED. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. GREAT A GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE THIS IS CARLOS
MACHADO WITH CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION RCSD AMOS
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE SB TWO
SEVENTEEN THE BILL WOULD MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR LEDS TO
OBTAIN MATERIALS FOR THE UNIT
ON SEXUAL HEALTH AND HIV
PREVENTION EDUCATION OR MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR IT. TO START.
I RAN THE BILL AND IT'S
REQUIREMENTS BY DISTRICT STAFF
CHARGED WITH MANAGING THE
CURRICULUM AND TURNOUT REACH. I
WANT TO SHARE SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK I RECEIVED DISTRICTS
HAVE FOUND THAT THE USE OF
TRAINED BILINGUAL STAFF. HAVE
BEEN MOST EFFECTIVE IN
ANSWERING A HANDFUL OF
QUESTIONS THEY HAVE RECEIVED
FROM PARENTS THESE INTERACTIONS
LEADING MOST OF THE CONCERNS
THAT PARENTS HAVE. DISTRICTS
ALSO HIGHLIGHT DISTRICTS ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED THAT PARENTS AND
OTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS SUCH AS
FAITH LEADERS AND COMMUNITY AND
NON PROFITS FOR EXAMPLE ARE
INVOLVED IN MATERIAL SELECTION
BEFORE THEY ARE USED IN THE
CLASSROOM. THIS IS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITY MEMBERS
INSPECT THE MATERIALS. BEFORE
THEY ARE ROLLED OUT FOR YEARS.
UNFORTUNATELY TWO SEVENTEEN
WITH THIS THE CURRENT SELECTION
DR COSTS. CURRICULUM USUALLY
HAVEN'T TO TEN YEAR CYCLE WHICH
WOULD BE CUT SHORT AS MANY
MATERIALS ARE NOT. AVAILABLE IN
TRANSLATION THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED BY THE BILL. I'M LIKE
MATH AND ENGLISH COURSES THAT I
WHERE YOU MIGHT HAVE TWENTY
FIVE OR MORE CHOICES FOR COURSE
MATERIALS. HI THERE MIGHT ONLY
BE THREE. SOME ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE IN SPANISH- BESIDES
ENGLISH IS TRIXIE LIMPLY DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES DURANTE FOR
THIS UNIT TO TAKE TRANSIT TAX-THEMSELVES THE BILL ALSO
COMPLICATE COMPLIANCE WITH
AUDIT AND MONITORING RELATED TO
THIS- ISSUE CORPS ELEAZAR.
LASTLY THE BILL PROVIDES NO
FLEXIBILITY TALLY AS THAT
CANNOT FIND DETAILS AT COMPLY
WITH ITS REQUIREMENTS IT IS
UNCLEAR WHAT OPTIONS ARE
AVAILABLE TO JUNE L. EA IT
CERTAIN TRANSLATIONS CANNOT BE
FOUND OR DIMITRIOS CANNOT BE
MADE AVAILABLE ATOMICALLY OUT
BECAUSE OF COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT
RESTRICTIONS. IT IS FOR THESE
REASONS AND OTHERS THAT WE MUST
ASK YOU TO VOTE NO ON THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MASSARO I THINK WE ALSO. HAVE-
JENNIFER CHAU. HI GOOD MORNING-
MY NAME IS JENNIFER CHILD AND
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU
GUARDING CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY YOUTH ACT OR GIANT
WHICH THIS BILL SEEKS TO AMEND.
SB TWO SEVENTEEN FOR NUMBER OF
REASONS FIRST CHILD ALREADY
ADDRESSED WITH LANGUAGE ACCESS
TRANSPARENCY FOR EFFECT AND-
AND START TO BALANCE THAT ALSO
INJURED BACK TO BILITY FOR
DISTRICT CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF
THEIR INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES. I
ALREADY REQUIRES AFFECT I'D BE
EQUALLY AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
ARE ENGLISH LEARNERS. AND THE
DIVERSITY OF EMAIL PROGRAMS
WHICH HAVE BEEN STELLAR TEETH
DIDN'T NEED. FOR CHOIR
CORRESPONDING CITY AND HOW
DISTRICT INTEGRATE TAX ADD
INCLUDING TRANSLATION OF
MATERIALS AND LANGUAGE
INSTRUCTION ALTERNATE
CURRICULUM OR SOME COMBINATION
OF THE- TRIAL ARE ALSO ALREADY
REQUIRED PARENT GUARDIAN
NOTIFICATION ABOUT THEIR RIGHT
TO REVIEW CURRICULUM. WHICH
DISTRICTS FACILITATE AND A
VARIETY OF WAYS INCLUDING
PREVIEW NIGHT INDIVIDUAL
APPOINTMENTS. AND IN THE RARE
INTENT NOT PROHIBITED. BY
COPYRIGHT. ON MY AND BE PROCESS
CAN TO EVEN OVER DISTANT
LEARNING. ANYTHING REQUIREMENTS
ARE NOT BEING MET AT THE- LEVEL
PROP THAT REQUIRED THE DISTRICT
PUBLICLY. SECOND TRANSLATION
UNDER THAN ENSURE MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT THIS BILL DOES NOT
FOR EXAMPLE ENSURE THE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT ACCURATE
TRANSLATION OF THESE OFTEN
SENSITIVE TOPICS. WOULD COULD
HARM MORE THAN HELP BY CREATING
MISUNDERSTANDING AND DIVERTING
RESOURCES AWAY FROM OUR
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
PARENT ENGAGEMENT. AND FINALLY
ASKED ME TO SEVENTEEN IMPOSES A
BURDEN REQUIREMENT ON TECH THAT
DOESN'T EXIST FOR OTHER TOPICS.
FROM WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
PAST LIFE OF THIS BILL APPROVED
A THIRTEEN DANGEROUS AND FALL
ANTI LGBTQ PLUS MESSAGING ARE
SINGLING OUT THERE ADD TO BE
MORE DIFFICULT. TO IMPLEMENT
AND OTHER INSTRUCTION. I WOULD
ON THE TO GO BACK TO THE DRAW
BOARD ON TAX AND DISPEL RAY.
ACTIVE PROVE IT EDUCATION ADDED
DIDN'T NEED AND- THE MOST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR IT
WILL GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO- TO
FOR IN OFFICER. SEEING NONE ANY
OP IN FORTY. SEEING NONE WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. BUT. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK UP
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WELL NOW GO TO LINE.
SIXTEEN PINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MINIMIZE THE MARA AND
I AM THE PARENT OF TWO STUDENTS
IN A UNIFIED AND I OPPOSE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. WHY. FIFTY GOOD MORNING
GLENN MITCHELL- GATE PARENT OF
THREE LGBTQ SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
HIS BIGGEST OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. ONE TO TWENTY
ONE. HI THIS IS SHANNON
OLIVIERI HOLDEN I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. PINE
TO SEVENTEEN. HELLO STEPHANIE
WADE ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA- MOTHER
OF THAT. EIGHT DIDN'T- IN
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND A FIFTEEN
YEAR PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
SOCIAL STUDIES AND PHYSICAL
EDUCATION I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FIFTY NINE. HI MY NAME
IS ROBERT GAMBOA FROM THE LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. BY. TWO TWENTY FOUR.
CAN YOU MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK. TO TWENTY
NINE. DODD FRANK MAN THREE
STUDENT AT CLASSICAL PRESENT A
STAMPEDE IN HIGH SCHOOL THEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU. BY. TWENTY THREE.
PRESIDENT MERICAN COLLEGES
OBGYN SIX OF NINE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. I'M SURE ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE A ANOTHER PERSON WHO'S
CHEWING UP WHO WISHES TO SPEAK.
JUST A MOMENT. ONE ONE NINETY
THREE. CAPREOL DURAN ON BEHALF
OF THE SECOND COUNTY COMMITTEE
OF CD IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE SHOULD SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE A CENTER GLAZER I
THINK YOU WANT BUSH TO SPEAK AT
THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA- I DID
NOT RECEIVE IN MY MATERIALS
THAT THE STATEMENT FROM THE
CHURCH OF LATTER DAY SAINTS-
THEM POURTANT THE TWENTY MINUTE
BRIDGE IF WE COULD ASK THE
CALLER IF THEY'RE STILL ON THE
LINE TO GIVE A SHORT ONE
MINUTE. SUMMARY OF THAT- THAT
POSITION SO I CAN BE ON THE
RECORD. PLEASE PROCEED. MISTER
WALKER OF. I BELIEVE I HAVE THE
LINE OF THAT PERSON JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
BUT I BELIEVE WE
HAVE THAT IN MIND. TWO TWENTY
SEVEN. TWO TWENTY SEVEN YEAR
ONE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR SENATOR GLAZERS
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION THANK
YOU FOR ASKING AT THE CHURCH OF
JESUS CHRIST OF LATTER DAY
SAINTS DID CONDUCT A SURVEY IN
THE FALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
AND THE TAKE AWAY WITHIN A VERY
LARGE PROPORTION OF THE AREAS
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
TRAILED RESPOND TO THE REQUEST
FOR INFORMATION AND IT WAS NOT
AVAILABLE THERE FOR ON THE
INTERNET. OR OTHERWISE. AND IN
SEVERAL DISTRICTS COULD BE A
BIG RESPONSE. THE RESPONSE HAS
WORKED SO GENERAL AND AM VERY
VAGUE. AND FOR THE MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. IN THE SURVEY WHERE
THERE WAS NOTHING ENTERED THERE
ARE. SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
PARENTS EVEN WHEN THEY AFFECT.
PERMITTED TO FIND WHAT CREEK TO
BE USED. AND ARE ONLY A- FEW
STATE REVIEW. SO IT SHOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD RESPOND
SO GIVEN. INABILITY QUICKLY NOW
WITH A OF A- TO BE A COUPLE.
HEAVILY INTERNET OPTION IN
ARGUE IS A WHITE THING TO DO TO
ENSURE CREDIT. AND PROBABLY
MORE FUNDAMENTALLY THE
REQUIREMENT FOR TRANSLATION. IN
OUR MINDS MAKES. A GREAT DEAL
SAN A LOT OF THE FACT YOU CAN A
QUICK. PORTION OF OUR- PARENTS
DON'T HAVE BY EAGLE OF THE
CRIME LINK SO WE WOULD. FOR
THOSE REASONS ASK YOU TO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU AND
THANK EACH YEAR FOR THAT MOST.
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL. YES TROUBLE.
AS SOMEONE WHO JUST LEFT THE
SCHOOL BOARD- LOCALLY AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT- THERE'S I ALWAYS ADVOCATE
FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND END. IN
GOVERNANCE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT
THIS BILL IS THAT WE'RE NOT
CHANGING THE CURRICULUM BUT
MAKING IT MORE AGE APPROPRIATE
AND HAVING THE- THE- CONSPIRACY
TO FOR PARENTS WERE ABLE TO SEE
AND REVIEW THE CURRICULUM WITH
THE MATERIALS. SO IT'S NOT
TAKING AWAY IT'S JUST ALLOWING
PARENTS TO FIND UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY JUST ALLOWING PARENTS
TO BE ABLE TO SEE THE MATERIAL
AND HAVING IT ACCESSIBLE VIA
pTO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S NOT
CHANGING IT JUST. MAKING IT AGE
APPROPRIATE AND MAKING IT A
VISIBLE AVAILABLE- VIA THE
INTERNET FOR PARENTS TO SEE AND
IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY- THE
DISTRICT'S ABILITY TO TEACH
THAT THE MATERIAL- BUT- BUT
ALLOWS PARENTS- IN WILD.
REVIEWING THE MATERIAL TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY FEEL
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN DEVELOPMENTALLY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE INSTRUCTION
OF THE MATERIAL- WITH THAT I
WILL BE SUPPORTING- MOVING
FORWARD ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FIRST OF
ALL I DO WANT TO THANK A CENTER
DOLLY FOR REACHINGOUT TO I
THINK WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION- I THINK-
APPRECIATE YOU REFERENCING PART
OF THAT CONVERSATION ALTHOUGH I
DO A POINT OUT THAT THAT WAS
NOT IN RELATION TO THE- SUBJECT
MATTER OF THIS BILL IS RELATION
TO ANOTHER TOPIC THAT WAS BEING
TAUGHT IN SCHOOL BUT THAT IT
DOES ILLUSTRATE. SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES- BUT- I ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOL BOARDS. I
MEAN THAT WE HAVE ELECTED
SCHOOL BOARDS AND I KNOW THAT
US. ON THIS ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
HERE'S AS A RECENT NUMBER OF A
SCHOOL BOARD. I DO WANNA BE'S
YUP- THAT. BEFORE WE IMPOSE
SOMETHING ON THE STATE WHICH-
WE OFTEN DO BUT- THAT- THAT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO.
ISSUES THAT ARE RELATED TO-
THEIR COMMUNITY. I THINK THERE
IS A ON BE CAREFUL THAT WE'RE
NOT ESSENTIALLY OPPOSING-
OVERLY ONEROUS- IT'S ACTUALLY
REGULATIONS OR RULES- THAT-
THAT MAY ACTUALLY INHIBIT-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FROM BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT THE JOB THAT
SHE'LL NEED NEED TO DO IN TERMS
OF EDUCATING THE CHILDREN-
ESTIMATE I. DO HAVE- YOU KNOW
THEY THINK THAT CONCERNS OF
SIDE IT MY COLLEAGUES IN A
POSITION COLLEAGUES IN AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF- OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS WHO HAVE
EXPRESSED THEIR OPPOSITION. AS
WELL AS THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY'S
CONCERNS. IT'S THINK- NEED TO
BE- THAT ADDRESSED- SO. I
APPRECIATE- CENTER DOLLY THAT-
YOU ARE OPENING A DIALOGUE I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT CONTINUING
DIALOGUE BY YOU NOT FEEL THAT I
AM AT THIS POINT TIME ABLE TO
VOTE FOR THE BILL AT THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING. BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO YOU THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU CENTER PAN CENTER
GLAZER. THANK YOU IT SURELY
I'LL ONE AS THANK- THE ALL THE
BILL FOR HIS SIDE A ENGAGEMENT
WITH AND COVER. I FEEL HIS
HEARTFELT CONCERNS ABOUT THIS-
ISSUE- IT I HAVE BEEN IN
GENERAL TERMS ALWAYS WANTED TO
BE CAREFUL- THAT WE SET A HIGH
BAR FOR SETTING STATE MANDATES-
AND THAT WE HAVE A LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LOCALLY ELECTED ENTER
AND RESPONSIVE TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES- AND THAT I
UNDERSTAND AND I HOPE THE
AUTHOR WILL CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG THAT THERE'S- NOTHING IN
CURRENT LAW THAT LIMITS THEIR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE THE
DISCLOSURES. THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING PROPOSED IN THIS BILL.
UNTIL THE LOCAL LEVEL AT
COMMUNITIES FEEL LIKE THEY WANT
TO GO FURTHER THAN THAT
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENT THAT'S
ALREADY ON ON THE AND THE LAW.
THAT THEY COULD- ACT. ACTIVATE
AND- AND ADVOCATE AND- AN AN
APPEAL FOR. ADDITIONAL
DISCLOSURES AS PROPOSED SO I
I'D I'D LIKE THAT
CLARIFICATION- MAYBE IN HIS
CLOTHES- BUT IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT- THAT
AND WHATEVER THE WAY THE
TESTIMONY FROM A WITNESS A FEW
MOMENTS AGO INDICATING WHERE
DISTRICTS HAVE NOT COMPLIED I
THINK THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE TODAY AND I THINK WE-
NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- FOLLOW THE LAW. AND
IT IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT HAPPENS
ON THIS BILL TODAY I THINK THAT
IT IS SOMETHING THAT- I WOULD
WANT TO BE SURE THAT THAT IS
FOLLOWED UP ON- BECAUSE THAT'S
WELL WHAT WE EXPECT WE PASSED
THOSE RULES AND THOSE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE DISTRICT
WILL COMPLY WITH THE SITE I
TAKE THAT VERY VERY SERIOUSLY.
BUT FOR ME THE LIMITATION IN
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY IS
THIS ISSUE OF LOCAL CONTROL I
DON'T DISAGREE ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY BUT IT SEEMS THAT
THAT- YOU DO THAT THAT THE CASE
FOR A STATE WIDE REQUIREMENT AS
PROPOSES. FOR ME IS A LITTLE
OVER REAHING AND IT'S A TOUGH
FOR ME TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BUT I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS IN THIS REGARD
AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS OF PARENTS AND THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
CONCERNED AND WANT THAT
INFORMATION THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET THAT INFORMATION UNDER
THE LAW TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. CENTER CORTESE.
YES PRIVILEGE WHEN THINK.
SENATOR DOLE FOR- HIS EFFORT IN
HIS CONTINUING A PERSISTENCE- I
THINK OF LARGELY FUELED BY AN
INTEREST IN TRANSPARENCY HERE
BUT I WANT TO ASSOCIATE- MY
REMAINING COMMENTS WHICH REALLY
JUST HAVE TO DO WITH- MY NO
VOTE TODAY WITH- MY TO THE-
CAUGHT THE TWO COLLEAGUES WHO
SPOKE JUST PREVIOUS TO ME SO-
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WON'T
REPEAT A RE HASH- THE BALANCE
BETWEEN LOCAL CONTROL AND SOME
OF THE DETAILS- THAT THAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT. WITH
IMPLEMENTATION SO. THANK YOU-
FOR BRING IT FORWARD AND WE'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO A CONTINUED
DISCUSSION. IN THE TIMES AHEAD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE CENTER DOLLY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES WELL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR NINETY. FIRST
LOSS YET TO ANSWER MISTER
GLAZERS- QUESTION YEAH YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT- BUT I'LL TELL
YOU I HAD THE REASON I GOT VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS BILL. IS
I HAD THE CONCERNED PARENTS OF
ROCKLAND. WHO WHAT HAPPENED WAS
THEY THE CURRICULUM WAS BEING
TAUGHT THEIR KIDS CAME HOME AND
THE- WE'RE EXPLAINING WHAT WAS
BEING TAUGHT IS GOING ON LIKE
THAT CAN'T BE RIGHT THEY'RE NOT
TEACHING REALLY TEACHING YOU
THAT AT THE STATE OR THE AND SO
THEY WENT IN AND ACTUALLY TRY
TO GET. SOME MATERIALS. AND HAD
A HECK OF A TIME GETTING
MATERIALS IN AND- WHEN THEY
WERE REALIZE THAT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THE CURRICULUM WAS PACKED
AND- WAS AVAILABLE AND- WAS
BEING TAUGHT- VERY OUTRAGED.
AND BY THE MATERIAL. AND WHAT
WAS BEING TAUGHT AND IT WENT
THROUGH THE PROCESS SO. THERE'S
A WHOLE HOST AND WE SAW THAT
WHEN THIS BILL WITH HER BEFORE
THERE'S AN- IDEA THAT CHOSE NOT
TO BRING A BUNCH OF- BUT TO
BRING THE- SUPPORT BECAUSE I
SAW WHAT HAPPENED LAST TIME I
THINK IT VERY MUCH FRUSTRATED.
THE PROCESS AND I. BET AND I
DID DO THAT SO I'M NOT GONNA
GIVE UP ON THE STUFF I DON'T
GET IT OUT HERE TODAY I WILL
THEN RAMP IT UP AND- AND MAYBE
MAYBE LEGISLATORS NEED TO HEAR
FROM THE FOLKS IN OUR DISTRICT
BUT WITH. WHAT HAPPENED TO THE-
CONCERNED PARENTS OF ROCK AND
WAS STATE THEY WERE BLOWN AWAY
BY THE MATERIAL AND IT WAS VERY
HARD TO GET. SINCE THEN THEY
WENT OUT STATEWIDE AND TRY TO
ACCESS MATERIALS AND IT'S VERY
HARD TO DO NOT JUST IN THEIR
DISTRICT OTHER DISTRICTS- AND
WHAT HAPPENED ROCKING WAS THEY
COMPLETELY CHANGE THE SCHOOL
BOARD- OVERTURN THE SCHOOL
BOARD AND SO. FOR ME IT'S LIKE
I DON'T LIKE I'M AGREEMENT I
MEAN IN AGREEMENT WITH. THE
FACT THAT I DON'T LIKE STAND.
STATE MINUTES I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
TRUST ME. I RAN FOR THIS TO TRY
TO STOP. THE STATE FROM DOING
THAT BUT IN SOME CASES. THERE
NEEDS TO BE IT AND THIS IS
BASICALLY TRANSPARENCY SO- AND
ON THE ON AND THERE WAS A
QUESTION ABOUT COPYWRITING. IF
IT'S COPYRIGHTED IS COPYRIGHTED
IT WHETHER YOU'RE- YOU CAN GO
PHYSICALLY LOOK AT IT OR GO
LOOK AT ON THE INTERNET THIS IS
BASICALLY JUST SAYING HEY THIS
IS THE CURRICULUM I'M GONNA
TEACH. ARE THE SCHOOLS GOING TO
TEACH. AT THIS TIME.AND HERE
IT IS POSTED WHAT DO YOU WHAT
DO YOU FREIDA I THINK THE L. G.
B. T. Q. ARGUMENT IS EVEN
BETTER THEY SHOULD WANTED UP
THERE AS WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING WHAT THEY WANT
TAUGHT RIGHT WE DO ALL KINDS OF
LEGISLATION HERE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE AT. THAT THEIR
GROUP HAS ACCESS TO. THE
INFORMATION AND THAT THEIR
STORIES BEING TOLD THE WAY THEY
WANT TO BE TOLD SO. FOR ME IT'S
LIKE. AGO IT WORKS BOTH WAYS
WHETHER YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IT'S ABOUT.
EDUCATION GETTING PARENTS
ENGAGE SO FOR THOSE REASONS- I
WOULD. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
DOLLY AND BEFORE THE PROMOTION
I JUST WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR.
THAT YOU DID ACCEPT ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE- PREVIOUS
AUTHOR WITH ASKED HIM TO TAKE.
AND ALSO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
CURRENT CURRICULUM. WHETHER YOU
LIKE IT OR HATE IT THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE A CURRENT
CURRICULUM THIS JUST PROVIDES
ACCESS TO PARENTS. WHICH I
BELIEVE AND I THINK AS A PARENT
MY KIDS ARE GROWN. UP BUT I
THINK AS A PARENT YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO VIEW THAT SOCIAL VERY
CLEAR IT DOES NOT CHANGE THE
CURRENT CURRICULUM. HOW DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
REMOVED THANK YOU SENATOR OTOBO.
WE HAVE A PROMOTION- AND
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM ELEVEN SB TWO
SEVENTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA. HI LEYVA HI- TROLENBERG
BY THE TROUBLED BY COURTESY NO.
CORTES A DE. DELI HI. SALLY I.
PLEASE YEAH. PLEASE NO MCGUIRE.
PAN. PENAT VOTING. THANK YOU WE
WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL A
MEMBER AND OUR OF THOSE. WE ARE
DONE WITH THE- MEMBER BILL AND
BILL AND AS A CHAIR HAVE SOME
TO PER. I AM GOING TO HAVE TO
GET OVER TO MY VICE CHAIR.
THANK. IF YOU GIVE ME ONE
SECOND TO GRAB MY ITEMS.
WELCOME SENATOR LEYVA YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL OR SENATE
BILL FIFTY ONE WE'RE GONNA
START WITH. FOR THE TWENTY
START WITH. THERE ARE TWO FIVE
OKAY YES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PLACE OUR WHOLE MEMBER. I
AM VERY EXCITED TO PRESENT TO
YOU TODAY S. B. TWO OH FIVE TO
PROTECT SCHOOL EMPLOYEES N
MEDICAL LEAVE ACT THIS BILL
WOULD REPEAL THE FORTY YEAR OLD
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING TEACHERS TO
PAY FOR THE COST OF THEIR
SUBSTITUTES WHILE ON EXTENDED
LEAVE. AFTER EXHAUSTING ALL OF
THEIR AVAILABLE SICK LEAVE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES MAY QUALIFY
FOR UP TO FIVE ADDITIONAL
MONTHS OF EXTENDED LEAVE UNDER
THIS BILL DURING THE EXTENDED
LEAVE THE EMPLOYEES PAY IS
REDUCED BY THE ACTUAL OR
ESTIMATED COST OF THEIR
SUBSTITUTE KNOWN AS
DIFFERENTIAL PAY. YOU MAY
REMEMBER THAT THE EXISTING
DIFFERENTIAL PAY LAW WAS
HEAVILY CRITICIZED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WHAT A PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER. FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WAS REQUIRED TO PAY
FOR HER SUBSTITUTE WHILE
UNDERGOING BREAST CANCER
TREATMENT. THE TEACHER
SITUATION RECEIVED NATIONAL
ATTENTION WHEN I GO FUND ME
PAGE WAS LAUNCHED BY PARENTS
FOR THE TEACHER. THE POLICY OF
DEDUCTING THE COST OF A
SUBSTITUTE FROM A SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES PAY DOES NOT AFFECT
ALL EMPLOYEES EQUALLY. IN SOME
CASES THE COST OF THE
SUBSTITUTE CAN EVEN EXCEED THE
SALARY OF THE EMPLOYEE. WHEN
THIS HAPPENS IT HAPPENS THE
EMPLOYEE ACTUALLY EARNS NOTHING
WELL I'LL ON EXTENDED LEAVE
WHICH IS PRECISELY WHEN THEY
NEED THEIR SALARY THE MOST
SINCE THEY MAY BE FIGHTING
CANCER OR A SIMILAR LIFE
THREATENING ILLNESS. WELL
OBVIOUSLY. ALSO STILL HAVING TO
PAY HOUSEHOLD BILLS. AND THESE
IMPACTS AFFECT VARIOUS GROUPS
OF EMPLOYEES DIFFERENTLY. EARLY
CAREER EMPLOYEES DO NOT HAVE A
LARGE AMOUNT OF STORE OF LEAVE
STORED AND ARE MORE LIKELY TO
FEEL THE HARMFUL IMPACTS OF THE
CURRENT POLICY. MOREOVER FEMALE
EMPLOYEES AT A PREVIOUSLY USED
THEIR SICK LEAVE DURING OR
AFTER PREGNANCY ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO EXHAUST. LITTLE
SICKLY THEY HAVE ALL REMAINING.
ON CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATORS AND
OTHER SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE AT
THEIR MOST VULNERABLE EXISTING
STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT THEY BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR EMPLOYERS
COST OF HIRING A SUBSTITUTE
THIS IS JUST WRONG. FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR STAFFING
CLASSROOMS ENSURING THAT OUR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE SAFE AND CLEAN SHOULD NOT
FALL ON OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EMPLOYEES
MUST FOR MUCH LESS THOSE THAT
ARE BATTLING AN ILLNESS OR AN
INJURY. JOINT JOINING ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TWO OH FIVE OR CAITLIN
VEGA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION INSEPARABLE
REPRESENTED CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. FOR
THANK YOU SENATOR LEVEL NUMBER
BONTA ANYONE ONE DISS TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT OF- WE HAVE LEAD
SUPPORT- WITNESSES CAITLIN VEGA.
IT YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS KEEP WHEN THEY GOT
ON BEHALF OF THE CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
THE SPONSORED THAT THAT B. TWO
OH FIVE UNLIKE MANY
CALIFORNIANS I HAVE SPENT THE
LAST YEAR TAKING CARE OF MY MOM
TO CANCER TREATMENT THANKFULLY
AT THE UNION RETIREES SHE
DIDN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
MISSING WORK BUT LOSING INCOME
BUT MANY WORKERS ARE NOT SO
LUCKY. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DEDUCT THE
COST OF THE SUBSTITUTE FROM THE
WORKERS PAID LEAVE OR TO
PROVIDE JUST A SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF REGULAR WAGES FEW WORKING
FAMILIES CAN AFFORD TO LIVE ON
SUCH REDUCED WAGES AND THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE THE LOWEST PAID WORKERS IN
EDUCATION WHEN SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ARE FACING SERIOUS ILLNESSES OR
INJURIES THAT REQUIRED THEM TO
NEXT WEEKS OR MONTHS OF WORK
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WONDER
HOW THEY WILL MAKE ENDS MEET.
THEY DESERVE SOME PEACE OF MIND
AS THEY RECOVER AND HOPEFULLY
RETURN TO WORK THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND WE
APPRECIATE SENATOR LEYVA FOR
INTERESTING THIS INJUSTICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH DO WE
HAVE A- TO- DOUCETTE BRAMBLE IN
SUPPORT. WITNESS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SEND REDUCE
MELISSA BROWN WELL I'M SPEAKING
THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND PLEDGES CATERS TO
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
TWO OH FIVE SHAPE WITH THE
SENATOR LIFTS UP THAT THIS BILL
PROMOTES FAIRNESS BY
RECOGNIZING THE ADVERSE IMPACT
THE DIFFERENCE OKAY HOUSE ON
THE TEACHERS ON ONE ON. WHILE-
INSTANCE OF AND GOING. ON
EXTEND LEAVE AFTER COST ALL
THEIR SICK AS WELL ON. THE ALPS
WHEN DID HANGING CLOSER. BECOME
THE SPONSOR ABILITY OF WORKERS
ONE- THE EMPLOYER. BUT THE
SENATOR. THIS ISSUE DURING
WHICH THE APPROPRIATE. WELL
WHEN ONE OF OUR UNIT MEMBERS
WHO WAS. SERIOUS I DON'T KNOW-
HUH THERE OF PLACE. TO IT FROM
PAYCHECK. WHILE SHE WAS OUT ON
THE NEXT OF THE I DON'T KNOW
OTHER PERSON. ARE YOU RECALL TO
PAY FOR THE CAR OF YOUR
QUESTION. BUT THE **** OUT NOT
BE DIEM RISK. AMOUNT IN YOUR
YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE KIND OF
STUFF ILLNESS AND ON TOP OF
THAT YOU GET IT. H. THAT WAS
CUT TO THE BONE BECAUSE YOU'RE
TO PAY FOR YOUR SO. THERE ARE.
SOME STUDENTS WHO ON LABOR
UNIONS THE- THAT HAVE COME WITH
WE DON'T BANG AS A ONE. TO HELP
TEACH AND THE DALLAS SECURE.
THE THIS BILL TO A BUT EVEN
THESE ARRANGE ARE COMPOSED AND
STUFF TO TAKE OUR PAYMENTS. FOR
THE CANUCKS SICKENING DONATED
BY THE- IT'S TIME TO REVISIT
THE BILL. AND OUTDATED PLICY
ON THE CAR THEY COME NOW THAT
I'M- IN THE STATE. SHOULD NOT
ASK YOU CATER TO PAY THEIR SO.
WE NEED YOUR- AVAILABLE ON
THANKS AND LEYVA THE LEADERSHIP.
FORT. NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. CNN ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
S. B. AT. TWO ZERO FIVE. CNN.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE BONTA INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO ZERO FIVE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
BUT WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THAT LINE SIXTY FOR ANYONE ELSE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO ONE SIX ZERO ONE
IS OPEN. WITH THE PHANTASM THE
HEALTH OF THE SEIU CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THANKS LINE TWO THIRTY
FOUR. STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES INSTRUCTS
THE COURT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIVE ONE
ZERO ONE. ON YOUR PEN YELLOW ON
THE HARDWOOD BOTTOM PEOPLE
CREATION POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE FROM THE AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN SUPPORT OF
TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER.
ONE TO THIRTY FIVE. WELL AS
SHAPING THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND WILL MAKE A
FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ADAM
CHAIR NO ONE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
ONE MORE TIME AT THE LINES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
FROM ALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
ON SB. TWO ZERO FIVE. THIS IS
THE FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. FOR
MADAM CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE
ANY- LEAD WITNESSES- IN. IN
OPPOSITION I'VE SEEN NINE.
RIGHT C. NINE. THANK YOU. LET'S
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES HERE ROOM
AT FORTY TWO OH THREE. CNN ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SB TWO
ZERO FIVE. SEE NON THANK YOU A
NUMBER TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECOM
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWO ZERO FIVE WE WILL BEGIN. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE THERE ARE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR IT
APPEARS THAT WE HAVE AT LEAST
THREE PEOPLE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. JUST A MOMENT
FOR THE FIRST PERSON. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. YOU MAY OPEN NOW GO
TO LINE TWO. TWO THIRTY THREE
PER LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF BACA
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO OH FIVE
THANK YOU. WHY. TO THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ANDREA BALL ON THE HALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY. TWO FORTY. GOOD
MORNING KYLE I'LL AND I'LL BE
HAPPY AT THE EASTERN OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS- I RESPECTFULLY
AND COMPETITION THAT FEATURE
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE OF THE
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CUTE PLEASE
OKAY M. CHECK THE LINE ONE
SECOND TO BE SURE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. THIS IS THE FINAL
CALL FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO I
AM SURE NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
MODERATOR. THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CNN.
SENATOR LABOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM VICE CHAIR MEMBERS THIS
BILL SIMPLY RIGHT OR WRONG A
TEACHER SHOULD TEACH AND THE
EMPLOYER SHOULD PAY FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE
CLASSROOM TEACHING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA WE HAVE
A MOTION ON SB TWO ZERO FIVE-
THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
CORTESE. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR CORTESE. THE
MOTION IS TO MOVE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I'D OF
THE THIRTEEN SB TWO OH FIVE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI PHOTO ABOVE NO THE TELEPHONE
NOW COURTESY ALL RIGHT FOR TEN
FEET HIGH DALLI DALLI NOW.
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN. WE WILL PUT
THAT BILL ONE CALL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH.
REPORTER THIRTY. TO FORTY FORTY
SIX SEVEN FIFTEEN FORTY SIX.
OKAY ALL RIGHT YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
SIX THE CHILD CARE
STABILIZATION FORMULA WOULD
ESTABLISH A SINGLE REGIONAL AS
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR CHILD
CARE PRESCHOOL AND EARLY
LEARNING SERVICES CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY HAS A MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES THESE
IMPORTANT SERVICES TO OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS SPECIFICALLY
IT HAS TWO DIFFERENT ONLINE
SYSTEMS FOR REIMBURSING
PROVIDERS THAT MEET TO
DIFFERENT STANDARDS. THIS
BIFURCATED RATE SYSTEM AND
INADEQUATE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
COMPLICATE EFFORTS TO FUND AND
DELIVER HIGH QUALITY EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS THAT
MEET THE DEVELOPMENT NEEDS OF
ALL CHILDREN WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING THE HEALTH SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF THE CHILDREN
THAT THEY ARE SERVING. ON A
LINE TO SYSTEM APPROACH LIMITS
ACCESS FAILS TO MAXIMIZE
PROGRAM QUALITY AND IS FORCING
MANY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS OUT OF
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS CREATED BY
THE CURRENT SYSTEM RESOURCE
EXPENDITURE SHOULD BE
STREAMLINED AND EXPANDED IN THE
FOLLOWING WAY COMPENSATE
TEACHERS AND PROGRAMS FOR THE
COST OF PROVIDING CARE. ON BE
RESPONSIBLE TO THE ECONOMIC
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZE THE COSTS OF MEETING
VARYING QUALITY STANDARDS
INCENTIVIZE HIGH STANDARDS AND
PARTICIPATION IN RESEARCH BASED
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN JUST ONE
AND NINE CHILDREN ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED THOSE
SERVICES. HOWEVER THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
TREMENDOUSLY INCREASED THE NEED
FOR CHILD CARE AS WE THOUGHT
PROVIDER SHUT THEIR DOORS AND
THOSE THAT REMAINED OPEN OR
FINANCIALLY SQUEEZED TO THE
LIMIT NOW MORE THAN EVER IT IS
TIME TO RESTRUCTURE HOW WE
REIMBURSE PROVIDERS TO ALLOW
THEM TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN
AND SERVE MORE CHILDREN AFTER
ALL WITHOUT CHILD CARE THERE
REALLY IS NO ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THROUGH THESE REFORMS
CALIFORNIA CAN ACHIEVE A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
MAXIMIZE. PUBLIC BENEFIT I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE STONE A
SNEERING. WITH THE CHILD RE
CENTER IN SOME. AND ALSO MEAN
ABOUT THE FROM EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE TO LEAD- WITNESSES- LET ME
BEGIN WITH THAT. DONIS NEED
SNEERING JR. GOOD MORNING AS
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
THOMAS NARINDER AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER AS WELL AS THE
CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES WE ARE. PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND HAVE
WORKED FOR MANY YEARS HE TRIED
TO SIMPLIFY AND MODERNIZE HOW
WE PAY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA HAS OVER
A ONE HUNDRED YEAR HISTORY OF
PROVIDING A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT CHILD CARE AND EARLY
LEARNING SERVICES. AND THROUGH
THAT EVOLUTION HAS DEVELOPED A
BIFURCATED REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM
HALF OF THE SYSTEM IS
REIMBURSED THROUGH WHAT'S
CALLED THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. WHICH IS
THE DAILY RATE THAT IS THE SAME
REGARDLESS OF WHERE YOU ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND DOES NOT TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE REGIONAL COSTS
OF DOING BUSINESS. IN HAS ALSO
FALLEN PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY
BEHIND- AND IS NO LONGER
COMPENSATING AT ACT. QUICKLY
FOR THE SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED. THE OTHER HALF OF THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE SURVEY
WHICH IS CONDUCTED EVERY TWO
YEARS AND REQUIRED. BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE WORKED-
NEED OF A I WERE CULTURE- A WAR
GROUP THAT PUT TOGETHER A WHITE
PAPER AND CONSULTATION WITH
HUNDREDS OF STAKEHOLDERS AROUND
CALIFORNIA. AND WE PUT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TOGETHER INTO
WHAT IS. THAT IS THE FOUNDATION
OF THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU
TODAY. THE BILL HAS WIDE
SUPPORT BY PROVIDERS IN THE
FIELD. AND IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO ADD ANOTHER LEYVA
MENTIONED CONSOLIDATE INTO A
SINGLE STRUCTURE THAT
ADEQUATELY REFLECTS THE NEEDS
OF THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. WE WORKED ON A
SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR AND WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL- BUT LARGELY
BECAUSE WE WERE HOPING TO BE
ABLE TO ALIGN WITH THE WORK OF
THE MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE SHE AND THAT
PLAN WHICH WAS RELEASED IN
NOVEMBER. DID LIFT UP THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM OUR
WORKGROUP AS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU NEEDED TO UNIFY
FUNDING AND ADVANCED EQUITY IN
OPPORTUNITY IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND CARE. TO THE
QUOTE FROM THE REPORT DIRECTLY
THE STATE THREE A CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE STRUCTURE IN
OVERLY COMPLEX IN AN EQUITABLE
AND NEEDS TO BE BETTER ALIGNED.
AND THIS GOAL CAN BE ACHIEVED
BY FOLLOWING PREVIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
RATE REFORM WORK GROUP. WE
WHERE WE HAVE MATT WITH THE
AUTHORS OF MASTER PLAN AND MADE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO THE BILL WE
HAD IN PLACE BEFORE. AND REALLY
FEEL STRONGLY THAT- WE NOW HAVE
A STRUCTURE THAT WILL HELP MOVE
US FORWARD- LASTLY THE QUOTE
AGAIN FROM THE MASTER PLAN
ADOPTING A NEW REIMBURSEMENT
RATE STRUCTURE PROVIDES IN
ANCHORAGE TRANSFORM THE EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE SYSTEM AROUND
THE KEY VALUES. OF EQUITY
INCOME ALREADY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WILL MOVE NEXT WITH
US LEAD. SUPPORT WITNESS NINA.
IS IT BUT THE MOVIE MOVIE. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS NINA B. T. I. IN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AVERAGE HOW
CALIFORNIA A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
SIXTEEN HUNDRED EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROVIDERS- ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE ALSO A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL ADDS
OUTLINED SB TWO FORTY SIX
OFFERS SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THE
BIFURCATED RATE REIMBURSEMENT
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. NEW RATE
STRUCTURE WILL INCLUDE ALL
STATE CONCERT I JUST HER
GROUNDS THAT FOUNDATION OF THE
MODERNIZE RATE STRUCTURE IS THE
BASE RATE SH WHEN FULLY PHASED
IN THE BASE WEIGHT WILL REPLACE
THE EXISTING RATE SYSTEMS AND
WILL BE APPLIED TO ALL PROGRAM
TYPES SBI'S BASE RATE WILL BE
ADJUSTED FOR MARKETS AND JONES
TO REFLECT DIFFERENT COST OF
LIVING THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF.
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM HERE FOR
PROGRAM TYPE I SISTER AND
CHARACTERISTIC OF THAT SHOW
START THE BAY RATE IT CAN. WITH
RECOMMENDED FROM MONSTER PLANT
EARLY. AND WILL BE INCREASED
ANNUALLY. THE NEW REIMBURSEMENT
RATE WELL OFF TO INCENTIVIZE
QUALITY AND PARTICIPATION IN
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE CHILD OUTCOMES THROUGH
EIGHT QUALITY FACTOR. ALL
PROVIDERS THAT MEET DEFINED
QUALITY STANDARDS WILL RECEIVE
THE BASE RATE AND THE QUALITY
FACTOR. NEEDLESS TO ENCOURAGE
ALL PROVIDERS REGARDLESS OF
PROGRAM TYPE TO ENRICH THEIR
PROGRAM ENVIRONMENT AND PAY FOR
THE INCREASED COST OF THESE
AFTERWARDS. LOCKSLEY THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A NEW CRISIS FACTOR
WHICH CAN BE USED TO DISTRIBUTE
FUNDS TO CHILDCARE AND EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS SERVING
CHILDREN AND ACCOUNTING
EXPERIENCING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. AS WE KNOW THE DATE
WITH THE CARIBBEAN PANDEMIC
BEING ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE FUNDS
DUE TO CRISIS AND EMERGENCY IS
MORE TIMELY THAN EVER SH THIS
CRISIS FACTOR MECHANISM CAN BE
USED ON A COUNTY BY COUNTY OR
STATEWIDE BASIS. WHEN A STATE
OF EMERGENCY IS DECLARED SUCH
AS THE PANDEMIC OR WILD FIRES
EARTHQUAKES EXTRACTOR. THIS
WOULD BE A SHORT TERM
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE. DURATION OF
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS NEW RATE
STRUCTURE SIMPLY THIS. RATE
LIAM SO AND HOW. ALLOWING A
MINOR MY ECHO APPROACH ALLOWING
ALL PROGRAMS- THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET PAID FOR THE COST OF THE
INVESTMENT. SIDE I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY SIX TODAY
THANKS SENATOR LEYVA BURGER
KING CAN YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL AND URGED I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND URGED AND I DO ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT- NOW WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HEARING. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. C. NINE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY SIX. SEEN ON. THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ARVENSIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWENTY TWO FORTY SIX WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MANAGER. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO. WELL FIRST OF ALL LINE OF.
SEVENTY FOUR. TIFFANY MATTHEWS
ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY. TWO FIFTY SIX. WE
HAVE A CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO FORTY SIX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS BONTA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF COUNCIL
FOR A STRONG AMERICA READY
NATION AND FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS AND DRUNK THE
COURT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND. TWENTY
THREE. ONE TWENTY THREE OH ONE
IS OPEN. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
LAND LINES ARE BACK WITH THE-
I'M SORRY RAIMES CAN JUMP BACK
I'M SORRY OF THEM YEARS RIGHT
SPENT ON BEHALF OF TRIPLE BE
AMERICA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLIND. TWO FIFTY THREE. TRUMP
EARLY EDGE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR.
TWO FORTY FOUR. HELLO THIS IS
WHAT YOU BOB YOU CAN WITH THE
LAMB CAMPAIGN GO COUNTY CHILD
CARE RESOURCE SERVICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY. TWO
FORTY EIGHT. HE'S HERE GARCIA
ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
THAT TWENTY THREE DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENTS AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE TWO ZERO THREE. GOOD
MORNING JASON SOMEWHAT ON FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION AND WILL
PRODUCE SUPPORT S. B. TWO FORTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER. BY. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT. HI THIS IS DANA
DOMINGUEZ ON BEHALF OF EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION PATHWAYS TO
SUCCESS AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO FOUR SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BY TWO OH THREE. PARDON ME
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
CHIU TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO BE SURE WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
ON SB TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE.
THIS IS A FINAL CALL IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
BUT I WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
MODERATOR. LET'S MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES HERE AND ROOM TO
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEN NONE.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHICH TESTIFIES
AND I'M SORRY. IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO FORTY SIX. SEEN ON. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES- LEAD
LEAD WITH WITH THE SERVICE. ON
OPPOSITION FOUR- SB TWO FORTY
SIX. WE HAVE NONE. OKAY NOW
WILL BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN. FORTY TWO OH THREE. C.
NINE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES A
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SB TWO
FORTY SIX. C. NINE. WE WILL NOW
OPEN IT TO OUR COMMITTEE. THERE
ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WISH
TO. I'M SORRY. THANK YOU WILL
NEVER MIND OR YOU ARE YOU. WHAT
IS WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE IS. MODERATE
ABOUT INTER. FRANTI INDIVIDUALS
IF YOU WISH TO. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. TWO FIFTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MANY EXPIRES I AM A TEACHER
INTERNET CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS READING
CENTER A DROPOUT RECOVERY
SCHOOL IN REDDING CALIFORNIA I
REQUEST AN EXCLUSION TO THE H.
U. G. MANDATE FROM CANADA'S AND
DROPOUT RECOVERY SCHOOLS LIKE
TURN YOUR TERM SCHOOL MA'AM
THIS IS THE WRONG BILL THIS IS.
S. B. TWO. IT'S UP NEXT SO
PLEASE HOLD. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
I'M SURE WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO
GO TO LINE. TWO FIFTY ONE.
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BEN CURTIS
I'M A TEACHER AT JOHNMYERS
CHARTER SCHOOL IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE- MASON COURT NORTH
BANK AND COULD COUNTY JAIL
CALIFORNIA. MA'AM THIS IS THE
WRONG BILL THIS IS FOR S. B.
TWO FORTY SIX. I WE'D LIKE TO
REMIND OUR CALLERS THAT ARE
RIGHT NOW OPENING THE LINES FOR
AB IN OPPOSITION TO SB. TWO
FORTY SIX. AND AGAIN WE WOULD
CAUTION THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
SPEAK- REGARDS TO THE BILL
BEING DISCUSSED AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO ATTEMPT WITH
BLIND TWO SIXTY IF YOU ARE
QUEUED UP TO THE CORRECT BILL.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
BUT BECAUSE OF THE CONFUSION
HERE I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FINAL
CALL HERE. FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OR IS
THIS BILL I BELIEVE YES PRESS
ONE ZERO. THANK YOU MODERATOR
ONCE AGAIN WOULD LIKE TO REMIND
OUR OUR CALLERS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY HEARING FORM
OPPOSITION WITH THE SAYS WITH
REGARDS TO S. B. TWO FORTY SIX.
MONITORED APPEARS BUT THERE'S
NO ONE KNEW SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY. THANK YOU
TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. HE BUILT. I HAVE A
REQUEST IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
ADDING IS A CO AUTHOR I'D BE
VERY HAPPY TO A WE WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE YOU MINIMIZED HERE
THANK YOU. GREAT BELL AND I
THINK IT'S VERY MUCH NEEDED.
THANK YOU. TINA THE MOTION HAS
BEEN MOVED TO- MOVED SB TWO
FORTY SIX. CONSULTED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I AM FIFTEEN SB
TWO FORTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HUMAN SERVICES LEYVA. LEYVA
HI OCHO. BY THE CHILUBA GUY
CORTESE I ATTEND THE US DALY.
KELLY I GLAZER. MCGUIRE CAN HI
AND I. WE WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL. OKAY CENTER LEVEL WE ARE
NOW MOVING FORWARD TO. SB THREE
ZERO NINE VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR HELLO MEMBERS
IT IS A PLEASURE 2% SB THREE OH
NINE THE COLLEGE ACCESS FOR ALL
ACT AS THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE I FIRMLY
BELIEVE IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
EQUITY AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY STUDENT CALIFORNIA
REGARDLESS OF THEIR BACKGROUND
OR CIRCUMSTANCE IS ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR FULLEST
POTENTIAL. IT IS UNACCEPTABLE
THAT ONLY HALF OF GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA MEET THE COURSEWORK
REQUIREMENTS TO ATTEND A UC OR
CSU AND EVEN FEWER SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
DISADVANTAGED HOMELESS ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND FOSTER STUDENTS
MEET THESE PREREQUISITES SB
THREE OH NINE WILL FINALLY HELP
TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
ALL STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST SB THREE OH NINE
ESTABLISHES A GRANT PROGRAM
THAT FUNDS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ACCESS
GRANTS TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WITH THE UC CSU A
THROUGH G. COMPLETION
COMPLETION RATE OF LESS THAN
45% OF ALL STUDENTS IN ORDER TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO A THROUGH G.
COURSES. AND ALSO FUNDS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL AND
SUCCESS GRANTS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES HAVE TAKEN
ON THE CHALLENGE OF
INCORPORATING THE UCC ISSUE A
THROUGH G. COURSE REQUIREMENTS
INTO THEIR LOCAL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS BUT WHO'S A THREE
G. COMPLETION RATES REMAIN
BELOW EIGHTY FOUR FIVE EXCUSE
ME BELOW EIGHTY PERCENT. WITH
AN EMPHASIS ON DIRECTING
FUNDING TO STUDENT SUPPORTS FOR
THOSE STUDENTS IN DANGER OF NOT
ACHIEVING THE NECESSARY GRADE
OF C. OR BETTER IN A THROUGH G.
COURSES SECOND SB THREE NINE
STRENGTHENS NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS AND PARENTS BEGINNING
IN THE EIGHTH GRADE KNOW THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE ATG
REQUIREMENTS WHETHER THEY'RE
HIGH SCHOOL HAS INCORPORATED
THEM INTO THEIR LOCAL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. AND
THEIR HIGH SCHOOLS EIGHT THREE
G. COMPLETION RATE AS WELL AS
THE RATES OF OTHER SCHOOLS.
WITHIN THEIR ELLIE A- FINALLY
SB OH NINE AT ALL HAS STUDENTS
ARE ABLE TO TAKE ALL THE
COURSES REQUIRED TO ATTEND THE
UC OR CSU IF THEY SO CHOOSE
WHETHER THEY ATTEND A
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL. A
CHARTER SCHOOL OR SCHOOL
OPERATED BY THE COUNTY SUCH AS
A JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL.
MEMBERS I WAS NOT AWARE THAT
NOT ALL OF OUR HIGH SCHOOLS
OFFERED A THREE G. SO TO ME
THIS IS JUST A HUGE EQUITY
ISSUE. YOU CAN HAVE A STUDENT
WHO IS GETTING A FOUR POINT OH
BUT BECAUSE OUR HIGH SCHOOLS
NOT OFFER YOU A THROUGH G. CUT
COURSES THEY CAN GRADUATE AND
NOT BE ALLOWED TO GO TO UC. OR
CSU SPEAKING IN SUPPORT TODAY
IS JESSE RYAN THE EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY CAN
MELANIE AND RAIL A PROMOTER
UNIFIED ALUMNI FROM THE COLLEGE.
FOR ALL COALITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JERRY LAY THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND GOOD MORNING TO THE REST OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
AS CHAIR LAY THAT THAT I'M JUST
THE RIGHT EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY. EIGHT
STATEWIDE POLICY RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN EQUAL
ACCESS. OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE WE'RE ALSO COMMITTED
CHIU COURAGEOUSLY ADDRESSING
RACIAL INEQUITIES IN EDUCATION
WHICH IS WHY WE FELT STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE COLLEGE ACCESS FOR
ALL ACT. SH I'D LIKE TO START
BY REALLY IT'S DISGUSTING THAT
THE DAHLE PANDEMIC AND RACIAL
RECKONING AND HOW IT IS
MAGNIFIED THE LONGSTANDING
RACIAL INEQUITIES AND COLLEGE
PREPARATION AND ACCESS. SHARES
DR WOULD AUTHOR OF BLACK MINDS
MATTER SAID. NGUYEN HUE MAKE UP
WHEN BLACK STUDENTS MAKE UP 4%
OF THE AT THE YEAR. AND TWO
POINT 5% OF THE UC POPULATION
DESPITE BEING 6% OF ALL COLLEGE
AGE YOU. WE MUST HAVE THE
COURAGE TO COMMIT TO REMOVING
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS THAT PREVENT
OUR STUDENTS FROM REACHING
THEIR FULL POTENTIAL SH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY TO REAP THAT REPORT
THE STATE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
FOR BLACK CALIFORNIANS. FOUND
THAT 60% OF BLACK HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES ARE NOT SUPPORTED BY
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL. IN REACHING
THEIR A THREE G. FORCE
REQUIREMENTS AND FURTHER MORE
LATIN ACTS. ARE NOT SUPPORTED
IN BEING COLLEGE PREPARED BY AN
ASTONISHING RATE OF 61% SH WE
KNOW THAT SENATE BILL THREE OH
NINE AND THE A. THREE G.
COMPLETION IMPROVEMENT GRANT
WILL EMPOWER SCHOOLS. TO BETTER
ADDRESS CAN BUILD A THREE G.
COURSE AVAILABILITY IT WILL
INCREASE COLLEGE ACCESS FOR
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WITH DREAMS OF
ATTENDING ONE OF THE STATE.
PUBLIC COLLEGES. ADDITIONALLY
AND THE OH NINE WILL BE ABOUT
TOOL IN A- BLACK IN LATIN ACT
STUDENTS REMAIN CALM. AND
QUALITY. BRING COMPLEX MAY
PATHWAYS THE- AND YOU. COACH
NOT DETERMINE YOUR DEATH. WE AT
THE STATE HAVE AN OPPORTUNE TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHERE THEY LIVE
I HAVE AN EQUAL SHOT OF
REACHING THEIR COLLEGE DREAMS
AND BEING FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
PREPARED. BOTH SYSTEM THE
COUNTRY CONSIDER HARMFUL
ADMISSION REQUIREMENT CHANGES.
AT THE CSU AND UC WE ALSO KNOW
SB THREE OH NINE WILL HELP KEEP
STUDENTS ON TRACK TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY. FINALLY I'D LIKE TO
SAY THAT ENSURING A STRONG
FUTURE FOR OUR STATE WILL NOT
BE REALIZED WITHOUT NEW
INVESTMENTS AND BLACK IN LATIN
THAT STUDENTS TODAY. BECAUSE OF
THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE COLLEGE FOR ALL ACT AND
RESPECT. RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISS RYAN. LET'S MOVE FORWARD
WITH MELANIE UNDRILLED. HELLO
MY NAME IS MELANIE ON THE RAIL
I AM A THIRD YEAR AT THE
COLLEGE AND I GRADUATED FROM A
ONE EIGHT FIVE EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- PHONE NUMBER OF THE
COLLEGE FOR ALL COALITION I AM
IN PROPORTION SB TWO ONE NINE
AS I BELIEVE IT WILL ALLOW
STUDENTS ACCESS TO THE CLASS IS
NEEDED TO BETTER PREPARE FOR
YOU SEE AND IF YOU. ARE I CAN
SURE THAT MANY OF THE QUESTIONS
CRUCIAL GROUP PREPARING ME FOR
COLLEGE WERE OFTEN OVERCROWDED
AND HARD TO GET ACCESS TO ALL
MY FRIENDS STRUGGLED IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND UNFORTUNATELY FAILED
THEIR FIRST TWO CLASSES OFFER
THEM COLLEGE WAS NOT IN THE
BOOK BECAUSE WE DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT WHAT IT WAS AND WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT IT FINANCIALLY-
ACCESSING COUNSELORS IN AN
OVERCROWDED PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL
CAN BE DIFFICULT. ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE ARE LIKE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY STUDENTS HER
GRADUATING CLASS AND ONLY. ONE
CONCRETE MIXER BEAT. BOB BECAME
A POSSIBLE. AFTER VISIT THE FOR
COLLEGE CAMPUS HIGH SCHOOL. I
THIS MOMENT FROM OF IS THE
FIRST WHEN WE FIND. HEAR
THOUSAND INSTITUTIONS. ARE BUT
BY THE TIME THEY WERE INJURED
BECAUSE THE BE THE TRUCK FOR
THEIR COMPLETE OF THE- COTTON.
FARM MIGHT BRING ABLE TO. ON
TIME BUT THEY'RE NOT QUALIFY
FOR YOU YOUR HERE TO- THE
8 DEGREES GRADUATE RATE POINT
ONE. IS FORTY TWO POINT 1% AND
I THINK THAT IS VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE. I NOT EVERY
THIRTY MINUTES BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO ASSESSING CLASSES. ARE
WHICH CAN COST. YOUR FALL
BEHIND. I A QUESTION HAPPENED
WHEN THE MERGER OF. OUR FIRST
GENERATION. YOU OR ABOUT- THANK.
I ASK EVERYONE WHO LISTENING
LEAD TO APART SB OH NINE OF
COLLEGE ACCESS ALL OUR IN ORDER
TO BE COULD ALLOWED THE TO
ACTIVATE FOR ARE NOT PUTTING
OUR DESERVES TO BE NOTHING WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO GOING AND
THEIR COMMUNITY ARE GETTING A
COLLEGE ARE YOU KNOW. DEGREES
THE LACK OF ACTIVE AND THINKING
SENATOR CONNIE LEYVA CURB THIS
BILL INTO LIGHT YEAH. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH. TOM NOW BEGIN WITH
WITH THE SAYS HERE A ROOM TWO
OR THREE. SEE NON ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WISH TO TEST ANSWER OF TWO ZERO
NINE. C. NINE. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCES MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE ZERO
NINE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
NOT- JOIN THE- TO MAKE COMMENT
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE FIRST COMMENT FROM LINE. TO
THIRTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MANY
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST HERE'S
CORD SB THREE ON THAT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY. TWO
THIRTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KEVIN
CORRIGAN AND I'M A SENIOR AT
WOODBRIDGE HIGH SCHOOL IN
IRVINE CALIFORNIA A PART OF
SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY SEVEN
SENATE BILL THREE OH NINE HAS
MY FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND. TO SIXTY FIVE.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANN HAWTHORNE I'M CALLING FROM
THE LOS ANGELES UNITED
METHODIST URBAN FOUNDATION AND
OUR KIDS CITY COLLEGE ACCESS
PROGRAM WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. A
LINE TO SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS BENJAMIN
TRêN ON BEHALF AND ON BEHALF
OF ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND PROBLEM
CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. WHEN I.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER LINE. TO
THIRTY EIGHT. ONE TO THIRTY
EIGHT YEAR ONE IS OPEN. EXACTLY
YES MA'AM THANK YOU I WAS GIVEN
A NUMBER SORRY ABOUT THAT-
DONNA CALLING ON BEHALF OF
COUNCIL FOR A STRONG AMERICA
AND READY NATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIVE TO SIXTY EIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR THAT HE'S CHRIS
WALKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL AND AIR
CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE LONG BEEN
ARE SUPPORTERS OF SKILLS
DEVELOPMENT FOR A SKILLED
WORKFORCE WE ARE NOT SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTED WE LIKE EIGHTY G.
IF IT COMES WITH C. T. D. SO WE
WOULD LIKE YOU TO STRONGLY
CONSIDER ADDING A SIMILAR
REQUIREMENT FOR CLEAR TECHNICAL
EDUCATION COURSES ALONG WITH
EDG SO THAT HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
NOT BEING FORCED ERROR BY ONE
TRACK IS JUST TAKE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AGENCY AND YOUR- YOUR.
INTENT TO SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
PLEASE. THANK I'M SURE THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS ACTUALLY. FORTY
MODERATOR YOU PLEASE CHECK THE
LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON SB THREE ZERO NINE
PLEASE. THIS IS THE FINAL CALL
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE NO ONE
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. ISRAEL AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOSELYN MORE
IN THE SCHOOL SITE COORDINATOR
FOR JOHN YOUR CHARTER SCHOOL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FACT UNA
REGIONAL CONSERVATION CORPS I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY RIGHT OFF
THAT I DO NOT OPPOSE THIS BILL
I SUPPORT THE GOAL OF THIS BILL
TO IMPROVE ATG COMPLETION FOR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. HOWEVER
I'M HERE FOR CONCERNS RELATED
TO THE MANDATE ALL SCHOOLS
OFFER COMPLETE EIGHTY G.
COURSES THAT CAN HELP THE TO
MANDATE BUT NEGATIVELY IMPACT
COOL FIVE NINE JOHN YOUR
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND MISSION
FOCUSED SCHOOL THAT PROVIDES
DROPOUT RECOVERY AND JOB
TRAINING WILL ARE. EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD THE OUTER
PROGRAM TO RECOVER ENOUGH
CREDIT HE'LL GET THE DIPLOMA
AND GO ON TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OR TO THE WORK FOR MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS TO READ WELL BELOW
GRADE LEVEL AND HAVE BEEN
FAILED BY TRADITIONAL
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. ARE ONLY
BE THROUGH THE WHERE THEY ARE
BY PROVIDING ALTERNATE PATH FOR
COLLEGE OR CAREER READINESS
WITH COURSEWORK HE LEADS TO
THEIR INDIVIDUAL. RIGHT THE
STATE THAT KNOWLEDGE THE
ALTERNATE THAT SYMBOL BY CARS
BY DESIGNATE THAT DOC. TURN IT
INTO PART OF THE RIGHT AREA.
NOTE THAT THE LAW REQUIRES ONLY
PROVIDE THE- THAT WE NOT- OFFER
EIGHT FULL EIGHTY CORRECT. THAT
CAN FIND A MORE PRO PRO THAT
THEIR GOAL. OKAY THE REQUIRED
LOCAL READ. AND IT. AWAY FOR
OUR CORE MISSION. THE RESEARCH
BETTER TOWARDS IMPROVING OUR-
DROPPED OUT WITH EVERY. BOB
THAN INCOME CORE. THAT WILL NOT
ACT. WELL BEING NO MANY DOCTOR
HERE TO FIGHT TOLD YOU AFTER
EIGHT G. IN THE- COMPONENT OF
THEIR PROGRAM. IT WILL NOT WORK
ALL BOB DOLE. THEREFORE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
CONSIDERATION FOR AN AMENDMENT
TO THE ATG MANDATE SECTION. SB
THREE OH NINE TO ADDRESS THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF PROGRAMS BY
CARS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MS MORE FOR YOUR AT
TESTIMONY. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
AND IT WOULDN'T IN UP HEARING
OF THE OPPOSITION FOR SB THREE
ZERO NINE. HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. C. NINE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. THREE ZERO
NINE. THANK YOU WILL NOT SEEN
NONE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE ZERO NINE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AGAIN
WOULD LIKE TO STRESS THAT WE
ARE ONLY ASKING FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. AND IF YOU DO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU HAVE NOT DONE SO ALREADY.
NOW GO TO WIDE TO SIXTY KILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MANY
FIRES AND I APOLOGIZE FOR. THAT
SPEAKING EARLIER AND THE FRONT
PANEL BUT I AM A TEACHER AT
JUNIOR TYLER SCHOOL THE
PARTNERSHIP OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPORATION CENTER
A DROPOUT RECOVERY SCHOOL IN
REDDING CALIFORNIA I REQUEST
UNIX COLLUSION TO THE A THROUGH
G. MANDATE FOR ALTERNATIVE AND
DROPOUT RECOVERY SCHOOLS. LIKE
JOHN THE CHARTER SCHOOLS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BYE TO. FIND. TWO
FIFTY FOUR. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KEEP LETTER
TO ME- AND I TOO AM WITH THE
JOHN MUIR CHARTER SCHOOL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CCC
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
IN FORTUNA CALIFORNIA- AS HE'S
BEEN MENTIONED JOHN MUIR
CHARTER SCHOOL IS A DROPOUT
RECOVERY PROGRAM AND I AM ALSO
REQUESTING AN EXCLUSION TO THE
H. U. G. MANDATE A REQUIREMENT
AGAIN SPECIFICALLY FOR
ALTERNATIVE AND DROPOUT
RECOVERY SCHOOLS. LIKE JOHN
YOUR CHARTER SCHOOL THANK YOU
HER. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TWO FIFTY. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MICHELLE
KISNER ANOTHER TEACHER CALLING
INCLUDE ON YOUR CHARTER SCHOOL
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS IN
SACRAMENTO- BEING A DROPOUT
RECOVERY SCHOOL I'D LIKE TO
REQUEST AN EXCLUSION FOR THE
AGING MANDATE SCHOOLS LIKE
MINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY.
TWO SEVENTY. HELLO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BETH KARAS IS I'M A TEACHER AT
CHANDLER CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
PARTNER WITH OUR LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS NORTH SPAIN
IN CANTANTE CALIFORNIA A
DROPOUT RECOVERY SCHOOL IN
KENTUCKY CALIFORNIA AND I
REQUEST IN THIS CAR POLLUTION
TO THE EIGHT THREE DEMANDED ST
FRATERNITY EVAN DROPOUT
RECOVERY SCHOOLS LIKE JOHN
MAYER CHARTER SCHOOLS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE BY. MY. TO FORTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS NICK USHA
I AM A TEACHER JOHN MADE HER
SCHOOL THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
SACCHARINE ALL REGIONAL
CONSERVATION CORPS A DROP OUT
OF RECOVERY SCHOOL LOCATED IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST EXCLUSION
TO THE A THROUGH G. MANDATE
FORM TURNED OUT OF SCHOOL BY
JOHN THEIR CHARTER SCHOOL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHITE. SIXTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CAPTAIN YOUR
WHOLE I AM A TEACHER GENERIC
ARTICLE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
PLASTER CENTER MANY OF MY
STUDENTS WORKING IN CONJUNCTION
WITH HELLFIRE AND I'M MAGLIANA
USES YOUR NAME AT YOUR AGENCY
AND YOUR DESIRE TO EITHER.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS BILL. I
DO WANT TO THE- NEW. BILL BUT
AND ACCEPT FOR ALTERNATIVE AND
DROPOUT RECOVERY SCHOOLS
BECAUSE OUR STUDENTS DO NEED.
BY. TWO FIFTY FIVE. ONE TWO
FIFTY FIVE OF ONE IS OPEN.
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
THIS IS EILEEN NAGLE AND I AM A
TEACHER AT JOHN MUIR CHARTER
SCHOOL THE PARTNER AGENCIES USE
CONNECTIONS IN SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA I REQUEST AN
EXCLUSION TO THE A THROUGH G.
MANDATE FOR ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS
LIKE MINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY. TWO SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU SEVENTY ONE YEAR ONE
IS OPEN. THE MOVE ON THE LINE
TO SEVENTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR SENATORS FRED JONES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
AND WE LIKE MISTER WALKER DO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT BALANCE
BETWEEN CAREER TECH ED. IN A TO
G. COURSEWORK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BUT I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE WHOSE SIDE SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU FOR ME WE HAD.
WE HAVE NO ONE. WOULD YOU MIND
CHECK IN ONE MORE TIME TH LINE
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES PLEASE. AND AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO.
BUT I'M SURE WE DO HAVE
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE OF SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK WITH
MEDICAL ALIGNED. TO SEVENTY
ONE. I TOLD YOU WHAT YOU WANT
IS OPEN YES SIR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS PETER
COST YES I'M A TRUSTEE FOR THE
CINEMA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND ALSO AREA.
TEACHER FOR JOHN YOU'RE
CHARGED- I WOULD SUPPORT THIS
BILL. IF AMENDED TO EXCLUDE
CARRY OPERATED ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND DROPOUT
RECOVERY PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER.
RICHARD BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE TWO
SIXTY NINE. HELLO MY NAME'S
LANCE GUNNARSSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRIAL AND
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION AND OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT CTE BEING LEFT
OUT OF THE PROCESS HERE AND UP.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WAS CLEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BUT I'M
SURE THERE IS NO ONE OPENING TO
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. THIS IS
THE FINAL CALL FOR ALL THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL. WE'RE
GOING TO ATTEMPT TO LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
OF ONE IS OPEN. IS THAT MY LINE.
YES SIR ARE YOU SPEAKING UP FOR
THE ENTIRE YES- CARLOS BURKE AS
I'M OUT THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION- WE WANT TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS BUT JOPLIN
MORE FROM JOHN YOUR WITH THE
COURT THE GRANT PROGRAM THAT
BEING PROPOSED AND ASK FOR A
NARROW EXEMPTION FOR
ALTERNATIVE AND DROPOUT.
RECOVERY CHARTER SCHOOL THANK
YOU. I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
TO ALL SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS.
DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. F. SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK
YOU ARE WELL FIRST I WANT TO
SAY THAT THIS IS A REALLY
REALLY GOOD DEAL AND- THIS THIS
FOCUS ON COLLEGE READINESS AND
THE AND THE LIMITATIONS THAT WE
ARE THERE ARE STARK IS- AS AS
THE STATISTICS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED ARE ARE TROUBLING AND-
AND- I REALLY APPRECIATE. THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING IN THIS
LEGISLATION AND THOSE WHO ARE
BEHIND IT- I WANTED AND I DON'T
THINK THAT YOUR- HERE
DIMINISHES CT- CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND I. I I'M GONNA
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO. SAY
SOMETHING ON THAT IF YOU WISH
BUT I DID WANT TO ASK IF YOU
WOULD SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE OF
DROPOUT RECOVERY. SCHOOLS IN
THE UNIQUE PLACE THEY HAVE A
AND APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
FEEDBACK TO ALL F US ON THAT
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER. WE ARE AND IN CONTACT
WITH THEM AND WE ARE LOOKING AT
WHAT WE COULD DO TO POSSIBLY.
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
MET BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS ARE MET AND IF THEIR
CURRICULUM IS SUCH THAT IT IS
ONLY. RECOVERY THEN WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THEM ON THAT.
WELL THANK THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND- I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT- THERE'S HAD SOME MERIT
TIME APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND- IF THERE'S
THE OPPORTUNITY I WOULD LOVE TO
BE- ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. WE'D.
LOVE TO HAVE YOU CENTER GLAZER
THANK YOU. SENATOR YES OF.
THANK YOU FOR I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALSO FOR THE RESPONSE OF
THE PREVIOUS QUESTION I
APPRECIATE THAT THE CONCERNED-
IF I CAN JUST EXPAND ON IT A
LITTLE BIT THOUGH- AGAIN I'VE
MADE THIS CLEAR TO ADVOCATES
WHO WHO APPROACH ME UP ON THE
BILL WITH REGARD TO THE
CONCERNED ABOUT A DROPOUT
RECOVERY AND SO FORTH- DROP.
WILL HAPPEN I KNOW AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER IN THAT I KNOW IS
A CHAMPION OF ADG WHO WORK WITH
SILICON VALLEY EDUCATION
FOUNDATION TO GO SCHOOL
DISTRICT BY SCHOOL DISTRICT-
OVER A FEW YEARS AGO TO GET
EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM TO
VOLUNTARILY COMMITTEE DIGI- IS
HEREBY CULTURE THAT CAMPAIGN
AND- I'M PROUD OF THAT SIZE
WILL MAKE CLEAR- WHERE I'M
COMING FROM. EVEN IN A CO TECH
WORDS OUT RATE IN. THERE SHOULD
BE. NOT JUST NOTICE IN MY
OPINION BUT THERE SHOULD BE. AN
OPPORTUNITY CREATED FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO DO WISH TO.
PARTICIPATE IN AB G.
CURRICULUM- THERE SHOULD BE AN
AFFIRMATIVE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT AND I SEE IN IN THE BILL
FOR TO BEGIN THERE'S FUNNY NO
BALL PROGRAM TWENTY OF ALL. OF
THAT PERHAPS IT OPPORTUNITY CAN
BE CAN BE TIED TO. TO THE TO
THE GRANT FUNDING THAT WILL BE
NEEDED- EVEN FOR DROPOUT
RECOVERY PROGRAM SESAY. OF FOR
EXAMPLE TO COUNTY LIKE MINOR IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- WHERE.
CONSERVATION CORPS OPERATES AS
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT TO SAY WE
HAVE ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAMS
WHEN YOU LEAVE HERE YOU CAN GO
THERE AND CAN. THIS IS THIS IS
HOW THE CONNECTION IS MADE NOT
JUST- BASIC NOTIFICATION THAT
WE DON'T HAVE IT- SO I DON'T
WANT TO COMPLICATE. YOUR BILL-
CENTER LEYVA I JUST THINK. IF
YOU ARE LOOKING AT TRYING TO-
BUT A- TO COME. ABOUT THAT
DIFFERENT MODELS- THAT PERHAPS
THERE'S AN ABILITY TO. TO MAKE
IT MORE THAN I A CAR ABOUT OR-
A MISSING IN ACTION TYPE-
APPROACH BUT- AN AFFIRMATIVE
REQUIREMENT THAT- OPPORTUNITIES
BE CREATED FOR THOSE IN NEED-
SECONDLY I HAVE A QUESTION.
THEN THERE IS A AS A READ THE
BILL I WASN'T CLEAR AS TO
WHETHER THOSE DISTRICTS AS LIKE
THE ONES I WAS JUST DESCRIBING
WHERE I WAS INVOLVED IN
CAMPAIGN WHO ARE. WHO HAVE UP
TILL NOW YOU KNOW COMMITTED AND
OBVIOUSLY THEY HAD THE LOCAL
CONTROL TO DO THAT COMMITTED TO
THE PROGRAM'S. REALLY DON'T
NEED TO BE INDUCED TO. THE TWO
EIGHTY G. BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THAT THE BILL
CAUGHT TO PUT IT SORT OF
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT- GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS SAID I'VE ALREADY
DONE THE RIGHT THING SO THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE. THEY'RE IN
THAT NOTE NO GOOD DEED GOES
UNPUNISHED CATEGORY. BUT THE
REALLY GREAT POINT NO THE BILL
DOES NOT DO THAT- WE DO HAVE
SOME CUT OFFS ON FOR THE
ELEAZER BECAUSE NOT DAILY EVERY
DAILY IS STRUGGLING. AS YOU
NOTE SOME OF ALREADY DONE THIS-
IN YOUR HIM DOING NO GOOD DEED
GOES UNPUNISHED I THINK MOSTLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THIS
BILL WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO THIS
BILL. IS BRING EVERYONE UP TO
THE SAME LEVEL- BUT WE SHOULD
DO SOMETHING FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
WE DOING THE RIGHT THING- IT'S
NOT INCLUDED IN THIS BILL BUT
SO NOTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF I MAY JUST- TO THE SHERATON
I DON'T. THINK WHATEVER. THAT
COME OF A FORMAL. THE MONEY
INTO SOME. OBVIOUSLY IT SHOULD
BE. TO A MUCH BIGGER LIFT TRY
TO. A DISTRICT FROM THE ZERO
GROUND ZERO ALL THE WEIGHT
EIGHTY G. AGAIN I KNOW THAT
FIRST HAND BUT- OF THE PERHAPS
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES TO AT
LEAST- HILL WHETHER SINCE THE-
SECOND SERVICING COSTS AND SO
FORTH FOR. A FOR OTHER
DISTRICTS THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING TO HELP THEM
MITIGATE THE EFFORTS MADE- THAT
SAID I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL I THINK IS HUGE YOU KNOW
STEP FORWARD- IN IN YOU KNOW
IT'S GREAT TO SEE- THE WHOLE
STATE. ESSENTIALLY BEING
ENCOURAGED TO COME ALONG ON
SOMETHING- THAT NOT EVERYBODY
IS DONE. THANK YOU. A SINGLE
PARENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
MAKE NOTE THAT- BACK IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN I WAS PROUD TO-
JOINT AUTHOR WITH THE CENTERS
DELEON AND HERNANDEZ- THE-
SIMILAR BILL- AND FACT IT ENDED
UP BEING A BUDGET BILL SO
THAT'S WHAT REFERS TO AND
ANALYSIS UP TO GET TWO HUNDRED
MILLION- TO. GET THE SCHOOL
STATUS PROPORTION OF BIRTH
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
LOW INCOME. FOSTER USE- THOSE
FUNDS SO THAT WE CAN BE SURE TO
GET ACCESS TO EIGHTEEN G. EIGHT
A. G. EDUCATION AS WELL AS
CREATING MORE SLOTS THAT YOU
SEE. FOR THEM AS WELL. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S MANY
API ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I DO AGREE
WITH CENTER CORTESE I MEET HERE
WHAT THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNED
ABOUT. BUT I DO THINK YOU KNOW
THE PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO SAY IS EVERY STUDENT SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO UC RIGHT I MEAN
WE THOUGHT. MOST- PROBLEMATIC
WAS THAT- REASON WE DID. THE
REGIONALLY- S. B. TEN FIFTY
BACK IN TWENTY- BACK IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN WAS IS THAT. YOU
COULD BE A STRAIGHT A STUDENT
AT A HIGH SCHOOL AND NOT BILL
TO GET YOU SEE BECAUSE THE
COURSES WEREN'T THERE. AT ALL.
AND SO I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE MAY BE CERTAIN
SCHOOLS WHERE THEY MAY BE DEBT
BURDEN SOME FOR THEM GIVEN THE
SPECIFIC POPULATION ADDRESSING.
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
AFFIRMATIVE PATH FOR ANY
STUDENT WHO IS ABLE TO DO IT TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE EDG COURSES
THAT THEY CAN HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT THEY HAVE THAT THEY ARE
TALENTED AND- WHEN THE WILL AND
ETCETERA I NINA. SHE THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS. BUT I
WOULD ALSO AGREE WITH CENTER
CORTESE THAT. IT'S NOT JUST A
CARVE OUT. IT'S SOME SORT OF
COMMITMENT THAT THERE'S A PATH
FOR THEM IF YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
THAT PARTICULAR SCHOOL THAT
THEY WILL BE FURTHER AWAY. SO
THEY COULD GET THE AG IF THEY
CAN DO IT- WELL I THIS IS A YES
THAT MANY OF THEM AND MAY BE
ABLE TO AND SO THAT THEY CAN
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO THEN
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION ARE
PUBLIC- UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
THANK YOU. AND THE EVENT THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND HAPPY
IN THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR PAN.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS I DO HAVE A
COUPLE JUST TO VOTE TO FORCE
CONVENIENCE FROM EDUCATION- I
DO WANT TO PUT IN A PLUG RIGHT
NOW I KNOW THAT THERE WERE SOME
STUFF TO YOU STATED THE VERY
BEGINNING ABOUT. ONLY A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF STUDENTS GOING TO
UC'S ARE CAL STATE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT I DO WANT TO PUT
IN A GOOD PLUG FOR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE EFFORTS THAT
THERE HAS. THERE HAS BEEN IN
THE STATE TO TRY TO ENCOURAGE
OUR STUDENTS TO ATTEND A LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THAT
MIGHT BE A SIGNIFICANT FACTOR
IN THOSE NUMBERS- SO JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT
THAT IN THE PUBLIC AS WELL BUT
THEY KNOW THAT- OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE BEEN
REALLY WORKING HARD TO GET OUR
STUDENTS TO GO ON THAT ROUTE.
FOR VARIOUS REASONS OF COURSE
SO JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT
ANOTHER CONCERN- THAT I HAD OR
NOT THIS IS NOT IT GET THE
PREVIOUS ONE WAS NOT A CONCERN
BUT JUST A COMMON- THE ONE.
OTHER COMMENT THAT I HAVE IS
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS- WITH
CHARTER SCHOOLS IT'S A CHOICE
FOR PARENTS TO HAVE THEIR
STUDENTS ATTEND TO THAT SCHOOL.
AND TO MANDATE- I FEEL A LITTLE
AWKWARD MANDATE IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS- WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO BECAUSE IT'S OPTIONAL
FOR PARENTS TO ATTEND THAT
SCHOOL AND IF IT DOESN'T MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE. THEY
THAT- EARNS WOULD LIKE THEN
THEY HAVE THE TO. ACCESS TO SEE
TO THE STUDENTS OUT AND PUT HIM
IN. SCHOOL IF SUPPORT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. OR ENDING AND NOT GIVE
THE SUPPORT TO CHARTER SCHOOLS
SO- THAT'S ONE THING THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE CONSIDERED IN
THIS BILL IS TO EXCLUDE OR
CHARTER SCHOOLS BECAUSE THAT
IS. OPTIONAL AND IF THEY DON'T
IF THEY DON'T OFFER THIS
COURSE. THEN PARENTS CAN OPT TO
ATTEND. AND SUPPORT OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS- IN ADDITION TO THAT
AND I CAN ADDRESS ALL THESE IN
MY CLOTHES OF THE GREAT NOTABLY
WONDERFUL- AND IT. IN THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR PUTTING
FOR THIS- I'M ACTUALLY A
LITTLE. DISHEARTENED TO KNOW
AND UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY. TO DON'T HAVE THE
MEANS OR THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
A TO G. WHICH I THINK THIS
WOULD BE A GREAT- FUNDING
FORMULA TO SET SUPPLEMENT THAT
BECAUSE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE IT ITS LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH STUDENTS.
SUPPORTING COURSE WORK. AND OF
COURSE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH STUDENTS SUPPORTING
COURSE WORK. THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE FUNDING TO PAY FOR TEACHER
TO ONLY TEACH ONE OR TWO
STUDENTS. IN THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ABOUT IS ANOTHER
CONSIDERATION THAT WE SHOULD
BE- VERBALIZING OUT THERE AS
FAR AS THE CHALLENGES FOR
SCHOOL LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IS THAT SOMETIMES THEY DON'T
OFFER COURSE WORK BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER THREE IS
SUPPORTING IT. AND THEREFORE WE
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY'S GOING TO
SUPPORT THOSE TEACHERS THERE
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERMAAK MATTER AT THE YOU
SENATOR. WE TALKED CLOSE EARLY
BUT EXCELLENT THANK YOU SO-
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
DISCUSSION I GREATLY
APPRECIATED. CENTER CORTESE I
WANT TO GO BACK TO YOUR-
QUESTION ABOUT THE FUNDING.
THERE IS FUNDING THE FIFTY
MILLION IN GRANTS COULD BE USED
FOR SCHOOLS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING. THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO THE A THREE G. SO. IT IT
GIVES IT A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING I HOPE THAT HELPS
A LITTLE BIT. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO KNOW ME THIS IS MY SEVENTH
YEAR AND- C. T. E. HAS BEEN A
HUGE HUGE PART OF MY WORK HERE.
IN ON IN THE SENATE. AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I'VE BEEN A
HUGE COMMITTEE COLLEGE A-
SUPPORTER AS SOMEONE WHO
STARTED MY COLLEGE CAREER. AT
MOUNT SAC IN THE WOMAN. WE WILL
ALWAYS WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS THE OPTIONS THAT
THEY NEED. I AGREE WITH YOU
CENTER CORTESE THAT ALL WE
DON'T WANT TO DO. PROBABLY JUST
A CARVE OUT BECAUSE YOU NEVER
KNOW A STUDENT COULD BE SPARKED
BY SOMETHING EVEN RECOVERY
STUDENT. THEY COULD SOMETHING
THAT SPARKED HER INTEREST. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THOSE A THROUGH G. REQUIREMENTS
TO GO TO A C. ISSUE. OR YOU SEE
SO I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR QUESTIONS AND
YOUR CONCERNS. FOR ME THIS IS
ABOUT EQUITY IT'S ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
OUR CHILDREN HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH THEIR
FULLEST POTENTIAL. SO WITH THAT.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA. TO HAVE THEM
OVER DO HAVE A- FROM. PAM THANK
YOU CENTER PAN THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED. THE MOTION IS TO-
MOVE THE- SB THREE ZERO NINE.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM SIXTEEN SB THREE ZERO NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THAT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA. LEYVA
HI- TROUBLED BY THE TROUBLED BY
COURTESY CURTIS III DALLY.
KELLY NOT VOTING GLAZER HI
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN HI AN
HIGH. I WILL PUT THIS BILL ON
CALL. YES BUT YOU HAVE ONE ONE
MORE BILL SENATOR LEVEL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PROCEED WITH SB
FIFTY FIVE SIX SIX PLEASE YES
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE A LOT OF BILLS FROM
TEAM LABOR TODAY. SB FIVE SIX
SIX ALSO KNOWN AS THE STEPS
STEPS TO ECONOMIC PARITY IN
SALARIES ACT WILL CORRECT
SALARY INEQUITIES THAT HAVE
IMPACTED OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
C. ISSUE SUPPORT STAFF FOR
DECADES IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
THE CSU UNILATERALLY DECIDED TO
ELIMINATE SALARY STEPS FOR
THEIR STAFF SALARY STEPS WHICH
HAD BEEN IN PLACE FOR OVER
FIFTY YEARS. THEY ARE THE ONLY
STATE AGENCY TO ELIMINATE
SALARY STEPS FORT SUPPORT STAFF
AND IS CURRENTLY THE ONLY STATE
AGENCY THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE
SALARY STEPS AS A RESULT STAFF
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO PROGRESS
IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER COMPARED
TO THEIR COUNTERPARTS FOR
EXAMPLE ON AVERAGE NEW HIRES
EARNED ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DOLLARS PER MONTH MORE
THAN THEIR PEERS WHO DO THE
EXACT SAME JOB. THIS
MARGINALIZATION ISN'T ONLY
UNFAIR IT'S DEMORALIZING FOR
THE HARD WORKING EMPLOYEES A
KEEPER CSU SYSTEM FUNCTIONING
MANY OF THE EMPLOYEES AFFECTED
BY THESE INEQUITIES ARE THE
LOWEST PAID CSU EMPLOYEES SUCH
AS CUSTODIANS AND
GROUNDSKEEPERS SB FIVE SIX SIX
WILL FIX IS UNFAIR SALARY
STRUCTURE. BY RESTORING 5%
SALARY STEPS FOR TWENTY
THOUSAND C. ISSUE SUPPORT STAFF
INCREASE PARITY WITH
CALIFORNIA'S TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE OTHER STATE
AGENCIES WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED
TEN THOUSAND STATE EMPLOYEES.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT TODAY. HE
IS SPEAKING WITH. OF FROM CA
FULL. AND DAVID BILL HAWKINS IS
ON WITH TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND
I BELIEVE THAT SHANE GROSSMAN
IS ALSO ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- HAVE WILL FIRST HEAR
FROM- VICKY MACLEOD IN SUPPORT
OF SB. FIVE SIX SIX. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE MORNING
SENATORS MY NAME IS A CAN CLOUT
AND I'VE BEEN EMPLOYED WITH THE
CSU FOR OVER THIRTY TWO YEARS
AND I WORK AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON I SERVE AS THE CHAIR
OF THE CSU EMPLOYEES UNION.
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. IF YOU
WERE YOU REPRESENTS SIXTEEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEE WHO
SUPPORTING OVERSEE THE ACADEMIC
AND OPERATIONS INCLUDING.
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
HEALTHCARE ADMINISTRATIVE AND
ACADEMIC SUPPORT BROWN'S AND
CAN STILL DEAL AT THE CSU
CAMPUSES. WITH THE INVALUABLE
HELP OF SENATOR LEYVA WE ARE
SPONSORING SB FIVE SIX SIX TWO
ONCE AGAIN YOUR SUPPORT TO
PROVIDE ANNUAL SALARY STEPS
FIRST YES YOU SUPPORT STAFF. WE
ARE GRATEFUL TO HAVE RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE PAST AND HOPE IT WILL
CONTINUE. THESE ARE NOT SALARY
RAISES RAISES ARE PART OF OUR
CONTRACT GIVEN TO ALL
EMPLOYEES. SALARY STEPS ARE
MERIT BASED INCREMENTAL
INCREASES RESULTING FROM A
POSITIVE PERFORMANCE EVALUATION
BY A MANAGER. FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THE CSU HAS BEEN
UNWILLING TO REINSTATE SALARY
STEPS DESPITE THE FAILURE OF
THE EXISTING CALORIE STRUCTURE
AND THE INABILITY AND EMPLOYEES
TO EARN A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
REYES. THE INABILITY BY SUPPORT
STAFF TO MOVE THROUGH THE
SALARY RANGES ALREADY SENATOR
LEE BUT- MENTIONED. IT IS JUST
A MORALIZING TO HAVE EXISTING
CLASSIFICATION ON THE SAME
CAMPUS FOR MANY YEAR YET HAVE
YOUR COUNTERPART MAKING MORE
MONEY THAN YOU. AND EMPLOYEE
SALARIES BECAME MARGINALIZED
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHT.
HERMAN SEE IF YOU MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS GREW AT TWICE THE
RATE OF SUPPORT STAFF. WITH
ANNUAL EARNINGS AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS. THE OUTER
AUDITOR CONCLUDED THAT THE CSU
COULD NOT JUSTIFY THE GROWTH IN
MANAGEMENT POSITIONS OR OTHER
COMPENSATION. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN STATE AUDIT REVEALED A
CSU BUDGET SURPLUS AN OUTSIDE
ACCOUNT THAT HAD GROWN TO FOUR
BILLION OF WHICH TWO BILLION
OUR ON GOING DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS. THAT CAN BE USED FOR CSU
OPERATIONAL COST. GOVERNOR
BROWN AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM BOTH
DIRECTED THE CSU TO PURSUE A
NEGOTIATED RESOLUTION AND
REVIEW THE COMPENSATION AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. LOWEST WAGE
EMPLOYEES. ALTHOUGH WE SOON
BEGAN. WE WILL SOON BE A
MANAGED LABOR TO RE OUR FOR. I
REQUEST YOU BARGAIN SALARY YEAH
HAVE MOSTLY BEEN IGNORED BY THE
CSU ADMINISTRATION. OUR
EMPLOYEES SHOULD NOT BE FORCED
TO WORK WITHOUT MERIT PAY THAT
OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE. ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE CSU IS ALLOWED TO
ACCRUE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
SERVE MY CLOUT WELL IN REVENGE
PRESIDENTIAL ACTIONS IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND JUST WRITING
COULD REALLY QUICKLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL NOW
MOVE ON. CHANGE BECAUSE- IF
HE'S AVAILABLE. YES GOOD
MORNING MADAM VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND AS A PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. THE
TEAMSTERS REPRESENT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA AND
REPRESENT SKILLED TRADES THE
STILL SKILLED TRADES BARGAINING
UNIT AT CSU. FOR US THIS IS
ABOUT FAIRNESS AND RESPECT FOR
THE HARD WORK THAT OUR MEMBERS
AND OTHERS AT CSU PERFORM EVERY
DAY. THE TYPE OF MERIT PAY
PROVIDED FOR THIS IN THIS BILL
CAN BE FOUND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AGENCIES AND SYSTEMS- AND
THE SUPPORT STAFF TO SEE IF YOU
ARE MIL LEST IS DESERVING THAN
ALL THE OTHER WORKERS IN STATE
SERVICE THAT GET THIS. GET THIS
BENEFIT- HOWEVER IT IS CLEAR
THAT SHE- IS NOT GOING TO
RESTORE THIS VOLUNTARILY- THIS
IS LONG OVERDUE AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR THIS MONTH.
WE WILL NOW. GOOD LISTEN TO OUR
THAN HER. NOW LET'S BEGIN OUR
WITH OUR WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
HERE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE. CNN
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
ZERO NINE. C. NINE. THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PARTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THREE
ZERO NINE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE WE DO
HAVE PEOPLE WHO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. ONE MOMENT
PLACE. THANK OU MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
ST COLLEGE REPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUAL WE WILL CONTINUE.
WHY TWO SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FEDERAL OFFICIALS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
PINE. TO SEVENTY FIVE. ONE TWO
SEVENTY FIVE YOU'RE ONE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES SIR. AFTERNOON RON RAPP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAD ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON JUST MOMENT
PLACE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
TWO TWENTY FIVE. EMILY
ROSENBERGER WITH AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA- IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ON CERTAIN. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I'M SURE WE HAVE
NO WILL TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR HE PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN JUST
TO BE SURE WE HAVE HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORT WITNESSES ONSB.
FIVE SIX SIX. THIS IS THE FINAL
CALL FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
HEAR FROM LINE. TO SEVENTY
FIVE. I BELIEVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS RON RAPP REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
HEARD MY TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CAN YOU PLEASE MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN JUST TO BE SURE THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON SB. FIVE SIX SIX.
A GOOD LEAD GERMAN WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A FINAL CALL FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. NO ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY WE
DO HAVE ONE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS MISS CHEN CHANGED.
PLEASE OUR ENTER LEYVA RIGHT
HERE. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY A GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE LEYVA CHAIR JOE
BOGAN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TENCHI FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CHANCELLOR PROFIT.
WANT TO SEE IF YOU HAVE THAT
OFTEN OCCUR THAT SHE ON AT THE
SIX I WOULD LIKE TO THANK HER
LEYVA THE MEDIA CHANCELLOR
CASTRO ON THE BILL. IT IS
IMPORTANT UNDER. THAT THE- THAT
HAVE LED US HERE TODAY DO NOT
OCCUR OVERNIGHT. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX THE STATE'S TOP
PROVIDING AND PAYING. ANNUAL
FUNDING INCREASE TO COVER THE
COST AMERICA. THAT ADDITIONAL
POINT. IF YOU IF YOU CONTINUE
TO PAY FOR DOWRIES OUT THEY'RE
BASED BUDGET FOR A DECADE. BUT
ULTIMATELY COULD NO LONGER
PAYING PRETTY INCREASE. WELL WE
MAY NOT HAVE HAD THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT CONTINUE PAY MERIT
RECAPS THE CSU HAS CONSISTENTLY
ADVOCATED FOR THE PRIORITIES
THAT WE SHARE THE LEGISLATURE.
INCREASE ACCESS IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES AND THE FAIR
COMPENSATION FOR EMPLOYEES.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE EVALUATE
EVALUATE AT THE FIVE SIX SIX IT
DOES NOT APPEAR TO ADDRESS OUR
INEQUITIES. RATHER IT READING
BUT IT REINFORCES EXISTING
SORRY AFTER THESE ARE REDUCE
ALL RATES WERE ALSO IMPORTANT
FOR YOU WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE
GAPS BETWEEN EXISTING SUPPORT
STAFF SALARIES. IN THE COURSE
OF TEN WE HAVE MADE THE
INCREASE WILL COST MORE THAN
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
TO THE SYSTEM. TO ADDRESS OUR
INEQUITIES. BUT THE ISSUE HAS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WITH OUR LEGAL
PARTNERS FOR TOOL CALLED NG
RANGER AGGRESSION OR I. R. P.
WE CAN BE INITIATED BY EITHER
MANAGEMENT. OR THE EMPLOYEE.
AND TWO TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
THE CSU HAS AWARDED MORE THAN
NINE THOUSAND IRAQIS TO SEE IF
YOU YOU EMPLOYEES. ARE BUILDING
AT TWENTY EIGHT MILLION IN ONE
ACCIDENT WHICH IS ABOVE AND
BEYOND THAT I CAN PERCENT
GENERAL SALARY INCREASES. THAT
RAIN. GIVES YOU THROUGH THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
IF YOU IF YOU DEDICATE DESPAIR
WILL. OTHER SIMPLY AND WERE TO
ADDRESS OUR ACTIVITIES WITH A
TOOL THEY RESOURCES AVAILABLE
AND LOOKING OUR BUDGET CAN.
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM THE
SYSTEM ALLOWED TO. TECHNICAL
OUR STRUCTURE THE CLOCK
BARGAINING. AT THE VALUE
INCREASE. I REFORM INITIATED
WITHIN THE RESOURCES AND TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO US. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING TO WORK
WITH- LEAVE ON THAT ISSUE. ON
THE LINE TO DRAW ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IS JUST OF DILLON SIX
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AT TO SEE IF YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY. MISS
A MYSTERY. ARE WE ARE NOW
MOVING FORWARD. JUST CHILLIN
SKI. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JUST GOING TO CONTINUE DIRECTOR
FOR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
ACTIVE HERE YOU ARE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES HERE AND ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. SEEN ON. ARE
THERE ANY WITH THIS IS A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISHES HAS A
FINE OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE SIX
SIX. THE NON. THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE TO UNTIL WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO
SIGNAL YOU WISH TO SPEAK. AND
JUST TO CLARIFY THIS IS- THIS
IS IN SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. FIVE SIX SIX. BUT I'M
SURE NO ONE IS SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MODERATOR WOULD YOU
MIND CHECKING HE LINE IT ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO BE SURE WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. THIS IS THE FINAL
CALL FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NO ONE IS
NOTICING TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS. DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OF THE BILL. SENATOR
LEVEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO. CLOSE
WITH A CLASS FROM NINE VOTE
THANK YOU. CENTER LEYVA. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR PAN
FOR SB FIVE SIX TO BE MOVED.
THE MOTION IS TO MOVE ON SB
FIVE SIX SIX CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM SEVENTEEN SB
FIVE SIX SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST WERE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA. LEYVA HI PHOTO ABOVE
ABSTAINED. THE TROUBLED NOT
VOTING CORTESE HI ATTENDS THE
OUTSIDE DELHI. KELLY NOT VOTING
GLAZER L. GLAZER NO MCGUIRE
FIRE HI PAM NIGHT AN ALLY.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ALL
MEMBERS BEFORE YOU GO THOSE OF
YOU HAVE VOTER ON EVERYTHING
LET'S VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DO WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR THE KILL THAT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLAR MOVES
THE CONSENT CALENDAR MA'AM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CONSENT CALENDAR LEYVA BY THE
VITAL TO ABODE I THE TROUBLED
BY COURTESY THANKS FOR TO THE
ONLINE DAILY. KELLY I GLAZER I
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE A
PAN NIGHT HANNAH. AND CALENDAR
IS THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHO HAVE
ON EVERY THINK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
TODAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO LIVE
CALLS ON BILLS WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
SENATE BILL SB ONE FOR AMERICAN
SALUTE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ITEM ONE S. B.
FOURTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FOR FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO
THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING AYE MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE HI
THE BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING
ON THE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
TWO TO FOUR. ITEM NUMBER TWO S.
B. TWO TWO FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO. SHARE
VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR VOTING
I. ACQUIRE THE BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO MOVING TO FILE ITEM THREE
SB TWO THIRTY SEVEN MEMBERS
SALUTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM THREE SB
TWO THIRTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. CHERVONA NINE VOTE
VICE CHAIR VOTING ONLINE
MCGUIRE. PAN ALL RIGHT THE
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO HAVING ON
THE FUNDING FOR S. B. TWENTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM FOR SB TWENTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING I'D THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. MCGUIRE PAN RIGHT
BUT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE
ITEM FIVE SB TWENTY SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS NUMBER
FIVE SB TWENTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CHAIR VOTING I. BY SURE HAS NOT
VOTED PATROL BOAT. OTOBO NOT
VOTING TALLY KELLY HI MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE I PAN RIGHT. PIMCO'S L.
SIX ZERO NEXT BILL IS FILE ITEM
NINE SB THREE THIRTY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
NINE SB THREE THIRTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER HAS
NOT VOTED. ULTRA LIBERAL. FOR
TROUBLED NOT VOTING DALY
TELLING NOW MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
PAN AM HI. THE BILLS OUT FIVE
TWO ONE THREE ON A FILE ITEM
TEN AS P. TWENTY TWO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
TEN SB TWENTY TWO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE CURRENT VOTE IS FOR ONE
JUROR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. DALY TELLING NOT
VOTING. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI THE
BILLS OUT TWO ONE S. B. TWO
SEVENTEEN FILE ITEM ELEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ELEVEN SB TWO SEVENTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS FIRST RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT
LOTUS THREE TO. THE CHAIR
VOTING ONLINE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE NOW. ARE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO FEELS PASSAGE
PARTY WASN'T WRITTEN WITH A
MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION
THANK YOU SORRY THE WORD LEFT
ME FOR A MOMENT THE BILL BE
RECONSIDERED. FILE ITEM TWELVE
SB THREE FORTY THIRD FOUR
THIRTY SIX SORRY THAT WAS ON
CONSENT. BOB ALLEN THIRTEEN S.
B. TWO OH FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM THIRTEEN S.
B. TWO ZERO FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTERS
TO CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO GLACIER. GLAZER NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN
AYE PAN AYE. THE BILLS OUT
FORTY TWO- WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN SB TWO FORTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. I AM FIFTEEN SB TWO
FORTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES THE CURRENT
POTUS FIVE ZERO CHAIR VOTING ON
A FIGHTER VOTING AYE. GLAZER
OKAY GOOD FOR AYE MCGUIRE. OKAY
BYE BYE BYE. I'M SORRY WHAT WAS
IT FIVE ONE THIRD BILLS ACCOUNT
SEVEN ZERO SIX SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HIM SIXTEEN
SB THREE OH NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM SIXTEEN
SB THREE ZERO NINE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO CHIU FORTY NINE VICE
CHAIR VOTING I DAILY. DAILY NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE ACQUIRE HI THAT
GOES OUT SIX ZERO. WELL ITEMS
FILE ITEMS. SB FIVE SIX SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM SEVENTEEN SB FIVE SIX SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING I- SIGNATURE VOTING ON
MY VOICE HEARD NOT VOTING BUT
CHOI BO. THE TROUBLE OF NOT
VOTING DELI DELI NOT VOTING.
THE BILLS OUT FOR TWO ONE.
SENATOR OF CHAU BOOK I THINK
THERE WERE TWO BILLS YOU SAID
THAT YOU DID NOT VOTE ON IT YOU
NEED TO VOTE ON WHICH BILLS
WERE THOSE SB NINETY SEVEN LAST.
SB. NINETY SEVEN. THOSE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY PERFECT.
SIX WHAT WAS THE OTHER ONE SB
TWO THEM I THINK IS ALSO A GOOD
PHONE CONSENT OKAY SO ALL GOOD
EXCELLENT OKAY LET ME GET TO MY.
TO EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE. OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE ALSO FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND- COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
IS ADJOURNED.